Musik Und du bist meistens mal in Köln? Das ist ja ganz irre. Du bist beim ersten Mal in Köln und wie hat dir der Dom gefallen? Hast du ihn schon besichtigt? Ich bin beim Bahnhof rausgelaufen und dann sieht man den halt. Er ist wirklich sehr gross. Sehr gross. Baustil, Gotik ist so dein Ding. Ja genau, das wissen ja meine wahren Fans. Ja, das ist ein Gotik-Freak. Ich bin ein richtiger GF, ein gothic-freak und gehe da auch auf Conventions. Kommt eigentlich gothic auch im weitesten Sinne aus dem gleichen Wortschirm wie gothic? Das hab ich auch mal gefragt. Also das sind Leute, die sich schwarz anmalen und sich ritzen, weiss ich nicht, ob das ist, ne, das ist Emu, aber so gothic-Leute, die sich dann Haarschwärze, sind die zumindest Fans vom Könnener Dom, weil es auch aus dem gleichen Kulturkreis kommt. Weiß ich nicht, kann auch sein. Sehr, sehr gezwungene Anekdoten. Ich finde das ein total natürliches Gespräch. Ich weiß auch nicht, alle Gespräche, die ich führe, enden immer bei Gotik. Du hast mich jetzt gar nicht vorgestellt oder so, ne? Nein, wir schneiden ja auch wahnsinnig viel. Also die Vorstellung kommt generell am Ende. Okay, sehr gut. So, wir fangen jetzt mit dem Mittelteil an, dann kommt der Anfang. Warte mal. Danke. Aber ich find's so schön, es ist grad so eine ganz tolle Atmosphäre. Es ist wie so eine WG-Party, wie so eine Küche. Ich hab mich auch gefragt, ob der schneidet, wusste ich gar nicht. Doch, wir schneiden manchmal. Ich schneide extrem viel, ja. Wir haben geschnitten. Wirklich jetzt, also. Er hat sogar in der letzten Folge sogar noch mal was neu eingesprochen, was man gar nicht merkt. Einmal hab ich jetzt wirklich, einmal, ohne Scheiß. Aber nur so ein paar Sitzel. Nein, wir haben einmal. Das finde ich so lustig. Ja, im Nachhinein. Ja, oder immer so mein Lachen schneide immer noch mal hinter seine Lacks. Hört mal hin, es ist immer dasselbe Lachen. Immer so ein Compilation aus Lurentis Lachen, so ein Lachenordner. Weißt du, was geil wäre, wenn du quasi im Nachhinein die Sendung halt wirklich schneidest und dann wirklich so dich so in den Sprech auch reinsprichst, sodass es nicht so unnatürlich kommt, das heißt, du bist alleine noch mal im Studio und machst so ja ja, blablabla, blablabla, und dann auf jeden Fall, und dann erzählst du so voll den guten Gang. Ich hab zwei Regisseure da hingesetzt, die mir sagen, das ist natürlich und nicht natürlich, und ich hab Micky Beisenherz, der mir noch ein paar Gags schreibt, damit zwar ich bin privat ein wahnsinnig unlussiger Typ. Ja, klar. Aber in der letzten Folge haben wir wirklich transparent gemacht, wann wir schneiden. Da haben wir, da hat Flo und ihn noch mal angesprochen, nachher geschnitten wegen schlechter Anekdote und so. Also wann und wo wir schneiden.
Da haben wir wirklich genau gezeigt den Leuten, wann wir schneiden. Aber jetzt mal zu dir. Genug zu uns, wir wollen auch mal ein bisschen über dich reden. Wir verstehen, also eine Sache verstehen wir nicht ganz. Und zwar, wie sind die Regeln genau? Es gibt ja die farbigen und die roten Kugeln. Und wir haben es so verstanden, dass wenn die roten Kugeln eingelocht wurden, dass sie dann nicht noch mal rauskommen und die farbigen schon. Oder also wie ist das?
Ich frag mich halt, wie lange musst du diesen Satz machen, damit der Gag wirklich auch zündet. Jetzt ganz offensichtlich war, nach den roten Kugeln war ich schon bei dir sozusagen mit dem Gag. Ich frag mich gerade die ganze Zeit, aber gut, dass du es lang gezogen hast, weil ich habe mich die ganze Zeit währenddessen gefragt, gehe ich jetzt auf diesen Gag ein und tu so, als wäre ich jetzt Ronnie O'Sullivan und mach so ein bisschen, zieh diesen Gag total in die Länge und so. Sehr gut! Oder lass ich dich einfach so ein bisschen eklig auflaufen und sag so, wegen Ronnie O'Sullivan, ne? Aber ich find's gut, dass du dich richtig entschieden hast. Aber du hast ihn jetzt aber so eklig auflaufen lassen, aber auch sympathisch eklig auflaufen lassen. Danke, that's what I do. Das heißt, du hast jetzt gesagt, ich hab den Gag verstanden, mich aber bewusst dazu entschieden, ihn nicht mitzumachen. Genau. Das ist die arrogantes mögliche Permutation dieser beiden Variablen. Ich nenne sie gerne die Donny O'Sullivan-Variable. Genau, die Mathematik, die die DOS. Du bist der Eisberg und hast gerade die Florentin als Titanic auflaufen lassen, kann man sagen. Ihr habt es gemerkt, bei uns zu Gast, Ronny O'Sullivan, der weltberühmte Snooker-Profi aus Taschenbillard England. Das ist tatsächlich der einzige Kick, den wir uns vorbereitet haben. Der ist jetzt nach vier Minuten schon vorbei. Ja, wie geht's dir sonst so? Also du bist ja ... Wenn Google einem vorschlägt, wie man selber eigentlich, wie man eigentlich lieber sein will ... Good to me, meinst du? Also du gibst einen Donny O'Sullivan und Google sagt dir, meinten sie Ronny O'Sullivan, dem berühmten Snooker-Profi. Also Google sagt dir quasi, dieser Typ, nachdem du gerade suchst, es gibt einen cooleren, du meinst bestimmt Ronnie O'Sullivan, oder? Ronnie O'Sullivan, forget it, lieber den anderen. Habe ich ehrlich gesagt noch nie so gesehen, finde es aber wahnsinnig lustig, das so zu sehen, ja stimmt eigentlich. Aber ich meine, ich mache mir da keine Sorgen, weil ich bin ja keine wirkliche Person des öffentlichen Lebens, also deswegen, wenn man mich googelt, da muss man ja, braucht man nicht viel erwartet, es gibt ja keinen Wikipedia-Eintrag von mir. Da haben wir uns auch das Ärgerungsmacht. Aber ich meine, du bist ja ein Weltenbauer, also es ist ja immer schwer, dich in Worte zu fassen, du kreierst Welten, Klangwelten, also auch in Textinstallationen und so bist du ja zu Hause irgendwo. Und ich finde es eigentlich ganz interessant, wie du schaffst, da irgendwie interdisziplinär so eine eigene Sprache zu finden und dich da auch irgendwie so ganz wohl zu fühlen. irgendwie. Viele haben ja, bei vielen Künstlern merkt man ja, dass es immer so eine gewisse Aufgeregtheit hat, so ich bin jetzt Künstler, ich mache das jetzt hier. Und bei dir ist es irgendwie, auch wenn du erst noch relativ jung bist, merkt man einfach, dass du da schon mit einer gewissen Relax-Heil, mit so einer Chillax-Attitüde da rangehst. Und das finde ich so entspannt. Okay, also machen wir jetzt tatsächlich komplett die ironische Figur Donnie O'Sullivan, oder ist das eine ernst gemeinte Frage? Es ist eine ernst gemeinte Frage. Ja, ich würde mich ja nicht als Künstler bezeichnen. Als Comedy-Projekt. Naja, als erstes, in der einfach als Mensch. Okay. Aber was heisst das denn Mensch? Was heisst Mensch sein? Oh Gott, Alter. Schnauze, das ist ja furchtbar. Also, ich glaube, Florentin, ne? Ich darf dich doch Florentin nennen. Ungern. Ich würde mir jetzt wünschen, dass du die Frage gezielter stellst, damit ich die auch besser beantworten kann. Du kannst auch den Martin Sonneborn machen und sagen, sehr gute Frage, ich würde gerne auf eine andere antworten. Ich probier's nochmal neu. Ich bin ganz sympathisch. Wie, was muss ich machen, damit du mir die Nummer von Lena Meierlandruth gibst? Eigentlich musst du da gar nichts machen, ich bin ja ein netter Typ und dann deichsam wäre das irgendwie so. Könnten wir jetzt hier in der Sendung Lena Meierlandruth anrufen? Aber ganz kurz, was bringt dir das denn, wenn du die Nummer hast? Du traust dir auch nicht, würdest du die... Was soll das denn heißen? Ja, was würdest du denn damit machen? Sehr gute Frage. Alles darin nach dem Nummer. Das ist creepy. Natürlich würde ich sie anrufen. Alles aber creepy. Ich habe schon mal nach ihr gerufen, auf dem Echo. Da stand ich auf dem roten Teppich, also ich stand abseits des roten Teppichs. Sie war auf dem roten Teppich und ich habe ihr hinterher gerufen. Ja, aber das ist nicht so weit weg von dem Anruf. Nein, was quasi alle hundert Journalisten und Fotografen aufmacht. Ja, alle, die das stimmigem Ding haben. Wenn man jemanden persönlich schon mal angerufen hat, dann kann man ihn auch über digital, über die technische Elektronik anrufen. Das ist ja dann nicht mehr so weit weg. Also ich würde wetten, dass du, wenn du wirklich die Nummer jetzt hättest von Lena Meierlandruth, würdest du nicht anrufen. Du würdest wahrscheinlich so ganz nerdig erst mal auf WhatsApp adden, damit du sehen kannst, was du im Profilbild zu haben. Ja, genau. Und dann würdest du irgendwie so, du würdest einfach high schreiben, glaube ich. Aber wie ist das mit dem WhatsApp-Profilbild? Welches Bild wird da genau herangezogen? Weil ich verstehe das manchmal nicht und ich habe schon von Leuten manchmal gesagt bekommen, so cooles neues Profilbild und ich so, what, ich habe mich überhaupt nicht geändert. Nein, das muss man nicht ändern. Und ich dachte, das ist immer das Bild, das man als letztes versendet. Nein, auf gar keinen Fall. Oh Gott, komm mal, ganz johin. Warum habe ich einen Penis als Profilbild? Ja genau, warum habe ich so einen wunderschönen Penis als Profilbild? Ja, aber anders konnte ich mir das nicht erklären, warum ich das nicht. Wunderschönen grossen Penis als Profilbild. Aber das ist einfach nur, du kannst mir Facebook darüber anmelden, glaube ich, und dann hast du das Facebook-Profilbild. Wer macht das denn? Ich habe das ganz normal. Oder du kannst WhatsApp und dann kannst du einfach das selber einstellen. Das ist nicht so schwierig und auch nicht so schwierig zu verstellen.
Und auch nicht so schwierig zu verstehen, deswegen frage ich mich gerade.
Aber wann hast du das letzte Mal so laut gerufen, wie du kannst?
Also so aus voller Kehle, so richtig laut.
Was war das für eine Situation?
Als ich eure Einladung bekommen habe für den Podcast, habe ich superlaut Nein geschrieben.
Mitten in Berlin, so ein langgezogenes Darth Vader-Nein. Ja. Das glaube ich dir sogar. Wobei, du hast dich auch ein bisschen gefreut. Nee, ich habe mich wahnsinnig gefreut. Du bist extra aus Berlin gekommen, muss man mal ehrlich sagen. Ich bin extra angekommen und ich habe mich wirklich wahnsinnig gefreut. Ich höre ja wirklich, man muss jetzt auch, man soll ja immer, ich war ja auch in der Masterclass, von wie man gut da quasi Interviewgast ist, da gibt es so eine Schule, ich weiß nicht, ob du die kennst. Und da habe ich gelernt, dass man als Gast immer als allererstes sich sozusagen ein bisschen schleimen soll über den Gastgeber. Aber abgesehen davon... Alles, was du jetzt sagst, ist halt uncool. Werde ich nicht als Lob aufpassen. Aber warte mal, auch wenn ich es eingeladen habe mit abgesehen davon, ich habe ja gesagt, abgesehen davon, das war jetzt quasi so der Quatsch und jetzt meine ich es ernsthaft, dass ich ja wirklich tatsächlich Aschow, also hier, ich schwöre es, euren Podcaster wirklich sehr gerne höre und habe ich mich wirklich gefreut. Ich finde es auch sehr lustig.
Das ist tatsächlich das einzige, was, also ich muss mein Referat in der Schule halten und was ich bei Referaten in der Schule immer gemacht habe, ich habe nicht recherchiert oder so, ich habe meinen Bruder gefragt, was er zu dem Thema sagt und mein Referatsthema war Vorstellungsgespräche und habe ich meinen Bruder gefragt, so, hey, was geht, Vorstellungsgespräche, dann hat er gesagt, hey, eins, was ich dir sagen kann, wichtig ist, dass du bei den Vorstellungsgesprächen... Dein Bruder beginnt jedes Mal mit, hey. Pass mal auf, pass mal auf, pass mal auf, pass mal auf, pass mal auf, hey, komm mal her. Und zwar musst du so tun, als hättest du dich wahnsinnig gut über die Firma informiert und wie du das machen kannst konkret, ist, dass du sagen kannst, wenn es irgendwelche Magazine zu dem Thema gibt. Also angenommen, du willst jetzt in der Werkstatt arbeiten, dann kannst du sagen, ja, ich lese ja die Motorsport, sowas. Dann kannst du sagen, so Magazine. Und dann musste ich dieses Referat halten und habe dann tatsächlich am Referatstag gemerkt, dass das alles ist, was ich zu dem Thema weiß und es halt irgendwie so zwölf Sekunden füllt. Und es war dann so, dann musste jemand anders das gleiche Referatsthema halten. Die drei Leute mussten das gleiche Referatsthema halten und während der erstes Referat gehalten hat, mussten die anderen beiden draußen vor der Tür warten, damit sie nicht hören, was der erste sagt, damit die sich nicht dasselbe sagen können. Und wir standen vor der Tür und haben wirklich in aller Ernsthaftigkeit darüber nachgedacht, ob wir jetzt einfach wegrennen sollen. Ob wir einfach, weil wir beide, das war achte, neunte Klasse oder so, ob wir wirklich, weil wir beide nicht vorbereitet waren, dass wir einfach weglaufen und dann diese Lehrerin die Tür aufmacht, Adam, Florentin, einfach weg, einfach nie wieder gesehenes Land verlassen, einfach wegen diesem einen Referat einmal weg. Wo diese Momente sind, wo man das machen kann, wo man es aber nicht macht und deswegen eine bestimmte Richtung in seinem Leben einschlägt. Ja, aber ich finde das mit dem Vorbereiten ganz lustig, weil ich war nämlich letzte Woche tatsächlich bei so einem Bewerbungsgespräch und weil ich bin ja freiberuflich, das heißt, man kann sich aber für so ein richtiges Bewerbungsgespräch und ich weiß ja auch so aus Erzählungen, dass man ja bei Bewerbungsgesprächen, genau wie du sagst, sich vorbereiten soll, über die Firma, am besten noch so Funfact, gerade BWLern, glaube ich, das ist mega wichtig, dass du ankommst. Ich bin ja kein BWL, aber um das mal im Vergleich zu stellen. Ich komme da halt hin und habe einfach, das war so eine Stelle für Art Direction, das heißt, es ging auch um so Designzeugs und so, ich hatte da nichts dabei, so ne. Vielleicht auch ein bisschen arrogant im Nachhinein, aber dann so, ja, und dann ging es erstens darum, ja, wurde ich halt erst mal gefragt, ob ich dann was dabei hätte oder ein Laptop oder wo kann man was sehen und ich hab dann so in meinem Kopf war die Antwort total unarroganz im Sinne von so, nee, nee, braucht man nicht, komm, wir machen einfach so. Genau. Dann fällt mir aber auf, dass es gibt Fifty-Fifty-Chance. Entweder die Frau, das war ja so eine Frau, bringt mich da rein, da waren noch gar nicht die richtigen Dudes da, sondern die so, willst du einen Kaffee, kommst du jetzt mal hin?
Und die war da halt voll so von wegen, ja, also Fifty- schon, entweder die macht dann voll so, ja brauchst du auch gar nicht, nee, wir haben ja über dich uns informiert so. Und die waren dann voll so, ah, okay, ah, jo, ähm, können wir am Laptop dann bei uns was gucken oder hast du was vorbereitet? Und ich so voll eklig, dann so, nee, du, ich glaub da ehrlich gesagt nicht dran, ich hab mich nicht vorbereitet.
Alter, nicht schlecht, aber dann durchgezogen. Ja, aber dann ...
Blöd ist ja, wenn du nur einknickst, so, ich hab doch was dabei.
Nee, genau, stimmt eigentlich ja, also man muss ja dann auch das dann durchziehen. Und, äh, also schon mal der schlechtesten Start ever gehabt an dieses ganze Gespräch, und dann kam diese Duz da rein, und dann hab ich wirklich gemerkt, dass die dann so Fragen gestellt haben, so halt gezielt darauf, ob ich was über die Firma weiss, so, ne, so, aber so kom Sinne von so, du meint, du warst ja sicher informiert, du weisst ja, bei uns ist es ja so, dass wir den und den Kunden haben. Dass wir im Jahre 1800 gegründet wurden. Wie in so schlechten, keine Ahnung, Ben Stiller-Filmen, ich so, ja, ja, klar, klar, da weiss ich, weiss ich so. Auch so Fangfragen. Sodass es halt echt, ja genau, nach hinten, neuer Hände losgehen können, die haben gesagt ach so, nee, stimmt übrigens gar nicht. Und es gibt es gar nicht, wir heißen ganz anders. Lass mich dir einen Tipp geben, und zwar sind viele meiner Freunde Designer, und was die lernen mussten während dem Studium, mussten die lernen, gewisse Dinge zu schraffieren, und zwar also so über Kreuz zu schraffieren, weil du kannst ja nur so von links unten nach rechts oben schraffieren als Rechtshänder, beziehungsweise nur eine Schraffurart, mussten dann aber die Schraffurart lernen, die einem zuwider ist sozusagen, damit man das Blatt nicht drehen muss, damit man, weil es extrem unprofessionell scheint, wenn man das Blatt dreht. Das heißt, so bei so einem Forschungsgespräch könnte man sagen, schraffieren Sie doch mal diesen Raum hier über Kreuz und dann kann der Einstellende sehen, dass wenn der Bewerber das Blatt einmal drehen muss, ist es ein Anfänger und wenn der es einfach zack, zack, zack, zack, zack, zack, zack, zack, gut machen kann, dann nicht.
Also niemals das Blatt drehen, niemals das Blatt drehen.
Es war keine Schraffur da an keinem Blatt, also im Sinne von, aber wenn es das mal vorkommt, ein super Tipp.
Aber daran erkennst du auch beim ersten Date oder so, einfach schraffier hier mal die Rechnung kurz und wenn sie das Blatt drehen muss, ist es ein Anfänger, dann lieber nicht.
Ich traue einfach nur ein paar Tipps raus.
Bringst du zu deinen ersten Dates immer so eine Schraffur und so einen Schraffurstift mit, das würde einiges erklären.
Tatsächlich hat mir mein Bruder, ich finde es auch so gut, wie viel mein Bruder mir beigemacht hat. Diesen Bruder gibt es gar nicht. Das ist ja eine Gagswahl, wenn man diesen Bruder. Den müssen wir auch mal einleiten. Mein Bruder hat gesagt, es ist ganz wichtig, als ich es als ich lesen konnte, als ich angefangen habe zu lesen, hat er gesagt, es ist ganz wichtig, dass du auch falschrum lesen kannst. Also dass wenn du das Buch falschrum hältst, dass du dann auch lesen kannst. Ja, aber warum denn? Er hat gesagt, damit du mal, wenn du auf einem Date mit einer Frau bist, die Speisekarte, wenn es nur eine Speisekarte hat, gibt, kriegt sie die Speisekarte und du musst die Speisekarte auch lesen können. Was? Dann habe ich wochenlang geübt, Bücher zu lesen, falschrum, meine Mutter, ich glaube, meine Mutter dachte, ich sei behindert, weil ich aber jedes Buch einfach falschrum lese. Aber wie hast du es denn in deinem Kopf gelesen, also das Hirtenwettnis oder hast du dann einfach versucht, das richtig zu lesen? Du musst ja wirklich auch dann die Gerichte auf der Schweißenkarte und die Preise. Kannst du, dass du so ein Comedyprojekt bist von deinem Bruder? Genau. In Mitte meinst du alles ernst, aber er hat dich komplett verarscht. Warte, warte, fährt dein Bruder gerne mit dir nach Las Vegas und versucht dann, dass du Karten ziehst und du hast so einen kleinen Koffer dabei immer. Habt die F nach Fußgängerzone gestanden zum Hut vor dir. Ich muss jetzt Neo Magazin schauen, kann nicht. Aber wir haben ja tatsächlich übergeredet, wie wir unsere Kinder bewusst Scheiße erziehen würden, einfach aus Spaß. Wörter falsch beibringen. Ja, einfach falsche Bezeichnungen beibringen. Was wäre da ein Beispiel? Stuhl, nicht beibringen, das Wort für Stuhl nicht beibringen, das Wort für Hunger nicht beibringen, einfach mit Wörtern nicht beibringend einfach. Das streckt einen so ein zum Beispiel.
Das wüsstest du aber, wenn du die letzte Folge gehört hast, wie du behauptet hast.
Ja, haben wir damit gemerkt, dass es nicht gehört ist.
Don't you, don't you, don't you, don't you? Ah, da war ich doch.
Erstmal ein kleiner Test, nicht bestanden.
Was hat denn dir dein, was hast du so, was hat deine Familie dir damit so mitgegeben auf dem Weg?
Oh, meine Familie?
Du bist ja Irren, also du bist ja ausgewandert damals nach dem grossen Feuer.
Nach dem grossen Feuer, das ich gelegt habe.
Als Irland in den Flammen stand.
Ne, das war so, ich hatte in Irland, als ich so acht war, musste ich ein Referat halten und dann sind wir einfach geflüchtet. Er war weggerannt. Aber dass du den Gegner noch nicht kapiert hast, nach Referat halten, dass ich erst das mit dem Pflichten sage. Eigentlich war er ja schon damit. Ne, fand ich fand ich nicht schlecht jetzt. Okay, danke. Aber ich finde es auch gut, dass er die gesamte Familie mitgezogen hat. Genau. Alle mitgekommen. Nee, nee, nee, ernsthaft, meine Mutter und meine Schwester nach Deutschland ausgewandert, als ich so, ich glaube sieben. Ich habe lustigerweise, neulich ist mir gesagt worden von meiner Schwester, Superspiel mir jetzt 31, dass ich mein Leben lang, also bis neulich immer gesagt habe, ich habe in Dublin gelebt, bis ich neun war. Und dann habe ich das bei meiner Schwester so einen Abend gehabt mit Freunden da und ich erzähle das wieder, wie ich es immer erzähle. Und dann hat meine Schwester so, hä, was laberst du für einen Scheiss? Ich so, hä, doch neun. Hä, du warst vielleicht maximal sieben oder so. Und dann ist halt voll was in mir kaputt gegangen. Ich dachte so, hä, das Leben ist auf einer Lüge. Genau, mein ganzes Leben ist auf einer Lüge. Ich habe so, zwei Jahre sind einfach weg. Du bist ja nicht neunzwanzig, du denkstst, du bist älter als du bist. Genau, vielleicht, genau. Einfach zwei Jahre vergessen. Ja, zwei Jahre sind einfach weg. Wir sind dann ausgewandert, weil meine Mutter sich ganz romantisch in einen Deutschen verliebt hat. Meine Eltern waren damals schon getrennt und dann sind wir meine Schwester und meine Mutter nach Deutschland gezogen einfach und dann nach Süddeutschland, nach Tübingen, ins wunderschöne Tübingen. Dann habe ich da Abi gemacht und dann bin ich 2004 … Ah, du hast da Abi gemacht auf einem Gymnasium, ne? Auf einem Gymnasium, ja. Wo in deiner Klasse … ah, lass mich … denk mal kurz an ein paar Namen deiner Klasse. Genau, kannst du dich noch auf ein paar … Ach, warte mal. Jetzt wird's uneingeworben. Mit Schülerinnen? Warte mal, habt ihr was vorbein? Ich sehe ein G, ich sehe ein I, ich glaube da war eine Gilda in deiner Klasse, oder? Nee, eine gewisse Gilda in deiner Klasse. Ja, aber das war, pass auf, da hat die, wie warst du so in der Schule, warst eher so ein netter Typ. Ich habe gehört, dich ist Moderatorin geworden, oder wird jetzt Moderatorin. Ja gut, aber bleiben wir erstmal bei dir. Ich glaube, du warst eher so, du warst schon ein netter Typ, ne? Du hast also nie viele Probleme gehabt, auch immer gute Noten gehabt, oder? Warte mal, ey, warte mal, ich weiss noch, worauf du genau ausführst, netter, aber ich finde nett ist das falsche Wort. Ich weiss, du würdest darauf hinaus natürlich,, dass ich ein super Klassenclown war. Das war auf jeden Fall, aber ich war immer nett dabei. Auch zu den Mädchen warst du auch immer nett, vor allem. Du hast immer gut behandelt. Ja, aber die Mädchen in der ... Du hast jetzt keine Herzen gebrochen oder so. Du hast sie gut behandelt. Ich habe immer alle Frauen gut behandelt. Okay, da haben wir mal vielleicht ein kleines Video vorbereitet. Kannst du mal schauen, dass du das ... Okay, ist es laut genug? Ich glaube, es ist auch schon. I did not have sexual relations with a woman. Ja, das fand ich eine süße Idee von euch. Ja, gilt eigentlich mal fünfte Klasse halt, ne? Ja, oder neunte Klasse. Aber wie kam das zustande? Also wir haben da Geschichten gehört von einem schicksalsträchtigen Skilager, was ist da passiert? Geht einmal drauf ein. Ähm, Gott, ey, das ist jetzt ernsthaft. Es klingt wirklich so, als hätten wir gut recherchiert, wir haben einfach nur sauglück. Das ist ein Megagut. Ich muss echt sagen, ich war richtig beeindruckend so, das ist richtig so. Wir haben so einen Nebensatz, haben wir irgendwie gehört, dass irgendwer dich kennt. Das ist so Alfred Biolek-Style irgendwie so, ja, er lag ganz tief. Krass, oder? So ein bisschen Monitor auch, so wie die Politiker dann irgendwie konfrontieren mit dem Scheiss. Aber wie löst ihr das eigentlich nachher mit dem Video, dass man das ja gar nicht sieht? Es ist ja ein Podcast. Ja, wir wissen nicht genau, wie wir es machen. Aber wie hast du denn die Schule dann verlassen, also unter welchen Umständen ist das dann passiert? Also ich bin, das war damals auf dem Kepler-Gymnasium in Tübingen, da war ich ja nicht mega lang, sag ich mal so, da habe ich einen kurzen Zwischenstopp gemacht. Aber du hast Eindruck hinterlassen. Aber ich habe Eindruck hinterlassen, gerade bei den Lehrern und bei den Gilders dieser Welt. Ne, das war einfach Skischuleintheim, aber es war aber nicht fünfte, ich glaube, es war schon, das müsste schon siebte Klasse gewesen sein oder so, im Zillertal. Und da war es mega geil, weil ich da auch super gerne abends DJ gemacht habe mit dem neuen Album von Snoop Dogg, The Godfather, kam da raus. Ja, dein aktuelles Album heisst Monday is the New Sunday, können wir an der Stelle mal erwähnen, einfach nur, falls es gerade geht. Ja gut, aktuell ist gut, das ist ja Drum-Bass, das mache ich ja nicht mehr und das ist ja schon zwei Jahre alt. Aber das war tatsächlich bis heute das einzige Album, wenn man es Album nennen kann, was ich rausgebracht habe. Ja ne, und dann waren wir halt im Schullandheim und dann war das halt auf der, wie ihr grinst, ey. Also wenn die Zuhörer zu Hause wüssten, die ich hier gerade einfach mit Händereibenden angegrinst werde, weil sie hier nur, weil wahrscheinlich mehr Infos da sind, an die ich mich erinnern kann damals. Ob ich erzähl's doch, ich bleibe mir selber treu, wir sind da mit dem Bus nach Hause gefahren
und da war hier und da mal ein Flirt mit Gilda, weil Gilda es auch war und ist auch heute noch,
wie ich ja gerade im Video gesehen habe, wahnsinnig hübsch, gut aussehen und sehr, sehr intelligent.
Diese Frau ist ja krass, die ist ja irgendwie Ärztin und hat sich dann entschlossen,
irgendwie noch Politik zu studieren und irgendwie, also eigentlich wäre das ein guter Empfang gewesen,
damals im Nachhinein bereucht das, aber auf der Busfahrt war es doch immer so, da gab es halt noch die Nadine, mit der ich ja mal zusammen war zwei Jahre vorher. Die die beste Freundin von Gilda ist. Ja, aber da waren die nicht mehr beste Freunde und mit der Nadine bin ich ja zwei Jahre vorher mit ihr gegangen, ja das weiß ich nicht. Damit habe ich nichts am Hut. Und dann war halt die Busfahrt und dann war alles so ein bisschen gut drauf, sag ich mal, und damals gab es ja noch keine Alkopops und so, die Höhenluft und dann ist das einfach irgendwie so ein geil gemacht. Und der Bus, der Höhe geht 30 Grad im Bus, war auch wahnsinnig erregend. Und wir waren irgendwie alle so ein bisschen oben ohne und keine Ahnung, eins führte zum anderen und dann war irgendwie Nadine... Wir waren alle ein bisschen oben ohne. Ein bisschen oben ohne, wie auch gut. Ja, also quasi T-Shirts. Ja, okay. So, und ne, da haben wir uns einfach da so ein bisschen,
vielleicht mal geküsst und es war nicht gut von mir.
Bin ich nicht stolz drauf auf die Aktion.
Also möchte ich mich entschuldigen quasi.
Ne, entschuldigen möchte ich mich nicht, aber man muss auch dazu sagen,
einfach in die Rechnung mit reinnehmen, dass ich da halt zwölf Jahre alt war.
Juhu in der siebten Klasse, ist man zwölf Jahre alt.
Ist man nicht zwölf Jahre in der siebten Klasse?
Oder ne, da war ich älter, so dreizehn. Scheiße, wenn ich sagen würde, da war ich neunzehn. Aber wie hast du in die Schule, also wir haben ein gewisses Bild bekommen von dir als Schüler und was tatsächlich sehr interessant war, weil man das vielleicht nicht erwartet hätte. Womit Bild nennen oder Fahndungsbild? Du bist heute ein sehr in dir ruhender, gesetzter Herr geworden. Herr, ja. Und damals war das ja anders. Also wie würdest du dich als Schüler bezeichnen? Nee, ich war halt ganz klar, also wirklich der klassischste aller klassischen Klassenclowns. Also von oben bis unten. Letzte Reihe, wenn dann gemacht. Letzte Reihe, nur Quatsch gemacht. Grosse Schuhe. Und dann auch immer quasi, ihr kennt das bestimmt, also es gibt ja immer so eine Gruppe von Klassenclowns. Es gibt ja immer so es gibt immer so drei oder vier, maximal vier, meistens so zwei, drei. Dann gibt es ja meistens so einen Anführer, aber ich war nicht so ein Anführertyp, sondern einer, der halt noch ein bisschen krass, noch mehr unbeliebt ist bei den Lehrern, ich war immer der. Und das Ding ist, ich war immer, ich meine bis heute, das ist einfach an meiner, keine Ahnung, Ausstrahlung oder vielleicht an der Art, wie ich Sachen sage, liege, dass ich immer noch viel unbeliebter war bei den Lehrern als die anderen zwei, drei, mit denen ich Quatsch gebaut habe. Ich war immer der, der das abbekommen hat. Also es haben auch die dann selber teilweise gesagt, ich will jetzt nicht sagen, ich bin der immer ich-Typ, aber ich habe schon auch sehr viel Quatsch gebaut und sehr viel dummes Zeug gemacht in der Schule. Aber ich meine, so war das halt. Dass du natürlich der einzige Zwölfjährige mit grauen Haaren war, das hat natürlich nicht geholfen, um dich als Aussenseiter zu etablieren. Aber das ist irgendwie so ein Ding bei ihren, dass sie immer spezielle Haare haben. Also ich bin jetzt von meinem Klischee aus gegangen, rote Haare. Ja. Aber man wird echt erstaunt bei dir. Hast du übrigens wirklich heute wegen mir das dein Dublin-Irland-Til? Da wurde ich heute ein paar Mal gefragt, war mir sehr unangenehm, als es den Leuten aufgefallen ist, aber nicht wegen dir tatsächlich. Lack oben in meinem Schrank, das ist ein bisschen mein Ding. Also ich nehme immer... Hast du Angst vor der Frage gehabt? Ich habe wirklich Angst vor der Frage gehabt. Er hat tatsächlich auch als ... Weil ich dachte, ich habe mich instant gerechtfertigt, als dieser Vorwurf kam. Weil ich finde es mega unangenehm, wenn man sich für einen Gast anzieht. Das ist eigentlich noch eine Stufe weiter als Vorbereiten. Ich würde gerne wissen, was sich Florentin anzieht, wenn Lillermeyer Landruth mal zu weiss ist. Ein kleines Kleid anzieht. Ein schwaches Kleid, so Ohrringe. Auch die schöne Situation, als wir rausgegangen sind, um dich zu holen, weil du geschrieben hast, du bist da, hat Stefan nochmal auf dem Weg nach draußen, wir sind nebeneinander gelaufen und so gesagt, ich habe den Pullover nicht wegen Donny an. Das ist wirklich uncool. Ich habe bislang meine Kredibilität zu verlieren. Aber es ist schon geil, wenn du irgendwie einen Iren aus Dublin zu Gast hast, da hast original, die Zuhörer sehen, dass er nicht ein Pulli, da steht einfach Dublin Island, riesengroß. Er hat so ein Kleberat. Kein Turi-Pulli eigentlich. Aber ich finde es gut, dass sein Unterbewusstsein sich versucht, bei Donny einzuschleimen, einfach so ein bisschen völlig ungewollt. Aber warte mal, ich habe deine Frage, ich habe deine Frage gar nicht... Habe ich schon wieder vergessen. Die andere interessiert mich schon gar nicht mehr. Doch, aber interessiert mich, ich weiß nicht, was ich gefragt habe. Also ich war auf jeden Fall in der Schule in klassischer Klassenklauen und so ist es halt, ne? Und dann bin ich von der Schule geflogen in der achten, da habe ich zu viel Quatsch gemacht. Genau, darauf wollte ich hinaus. Also ich habe auch Quatsch gemacht in der Schule, aber wie fliegt man von der Schule, wie viel Quatsch muss man machen, um von der Schule zu gehen? Das war ganz ehrlich, rückblickend betrachtet ist das einfach zu erklären. Die Schule war auch ziemlich krass, auf der ich war, da haben wir alle sehr viel Scheiss gebaut, und die Lehrer waren, da waren auch teilweise echt richtige Psycholehrers dabei, also die waren auch richtig furchtbar, also pädagogisch nach heutigen Gesichtspunkten, also wirklich eine Katastrophe. Und wir haben aber sehr viel Quatsch gemacht, also sehr viel, bei uns gab es immer so ein System Einträge, ne, wenn du irgendwie, sagen wir mal, im Tagebuch steht halt drin, Donny redet während dem Unterricht oder Donny singt während dem Unterricht oder so ein Quatsch, ne. So, wenn du drei von denen hast. Donny masturbiert während des Unterrichts. Genau, das ist was man halt so macht, ne. Und wenn du drei von denen hast, warst du bei uns so, da kriegst du halt ein, also nee, drei Einträge ist gleich ein Elternbrief, so. Drei Elternbriefe, also dreimal drei, kriegst du halt Rektoratsarrest. Und darüber hinaus dann nochmal zwei Elternbriefe, glaube ich, dann fliegst du von der Schule, wirst du der Schule versuchten. So ein Highscore, ja. Genau, genau. Und lustig, dass du es sagst, wir haben das damals dann echt so gesehen, ich war nämlich am Ende des Schuljahres, wo ich klar war, ich flieg und ich bleib sitzen, aber ich ja noch in die Schule gehen durfte, haben wir halt so ein Battle gemacht. Ach so, weil das Polen offen, oder? Wir haben halt so die meisten Einträge bekommen. Das ist ja wirklich eine Lücke im System. Ja, das war ein bisschen wie ein Fehler in der Matrix. Wir haben dann einfach komplett ausgerastet. Das ist ja echt uncool. Das ist ja wie ein Fussballspiel, was schon lange verloren ist. Was schon abgepfiffen ist und die dürfen noch spielen. Ja, oder so. Ich muss ehrlich sagen, als ich deinen Namen, glaube ich, vor siebeneinhalb Jahren das erste Mal gehört habe, Donny O'Sullivan, dachte ich erst mal, so heisst kein Mensch. Weil das ist so ein cooler Name, das ist so ein fucking bader Name. Also Ronny O'Sullivan kann man nicht vorstellen, aber Donny O'Sullivan? Nee, aber habe ich glaube ich mal gesagt, also wir haben, als wir gestern das Geisterband gehört haben, zum ersten Mal haben wir doch hier glaube ich auch, aber wenn wir Nils Burkelberg sogar erw ich erwähnt, hast du sogar gesagt, genau, habe ich gesagt, das ist der coolste Name der Welt. Und mir ist aufgefallen, dieses O, dieses O vollem Namen. Ich glaube, ich kenne niemanden, der nicht berühmt ist und den O vollem Namen hat, was klar ist, weil, also, ich kenne wenig ausländische Namen, aber... Aber Iren sind ganz gut, glaube ich, weil ich glaube, man kennt nur positive Iren, Conan O'Brien zum Beispiel, Man kennt keine negativen Iren, irgendwie, Blackbeard oder sowas.
Man kennt eigentlich nur coole positive Iren.
Liam Neeson.
Das ist halt, glaube ich, einer so.
Aber auch zum Beispiel Liam Neeson.
Er ist auch ein wahnsinnig tolles Volk. Ich bin auch wirklich sehr, sehr, muss ich sagen, sehr nationalstolz.
Aber was ist in der schlechtesten Iren?
Ray Garvey.
Gibt's nicht.
Doch, Ray Garvey, glaube ich, ist in der schlechtesten Iren.
Nee, Ray Garvey hätte ich vielleicht auch gesagt, habe aber tatsächlich so einen gemeinsamen Freund, den ich persönlich sehr, sehr cool finde und der hat mir das versichert und wenn er das sagt, dann ist er, der scheint wohl super in Ordnung zu sein, Ray Garvey, ein sehr cooler Typ zu sein. Aber den kennt niemand in Irland. Das hat für mich den Mythos Ray Garvey komplett zerstört. Kenn ich aber auch nicht ehrlich gesagt. Er hat plötzlich auch dieses neue Album irgendwie aufgenommen, wo er meinte, er Back to the Roots, nur so irische Klänge da drauf und dann macht ein Kumpel ein Auslandssemester in Irland und niemand kennt Ray Garvey da. Dein aktuelles Album heisst ja All This Time. Was ist denn in dieser Zeit? Also wie jetzt welche Frage? Ich finde es übrigens eine gute Frage mit dem schlechten Iren, ich weiß genau, was du meinst, aber kann ich dir echt auch keinen nennen. Ich glaube, du hast es gut beobachtet. Irland ist halt so ein Volk, was halt viele... Doch, Irland ist halt... Vielleicht spricht ein bisschen mein Stolz dazu, aber man muss zugeben, Irland ist ein sehr kleines, wir haben vier Millionen Einwohner. Das ist das Problem. Und man kennt so wenig Iren, als dass man sagen könnte, der gute Teil ist, ist jetzt der schlechteste Iren dabei. Aber die haben historisch auch einfach alles richtig gemacht. Die haben nie irgendwie sich was anmerken lassen. Naja, diese ganzen Glaubenskriege sind schon... Wir sind ja immer... Das ist auch ein Schottland. Das ist ein Land, das immer überfallen, also quasi immer drunter gelitten hat. Ja, klar, gelitten. Der Braverdut ist übrigens Schotte. Auch Protestanten gegen Katholiken ist auch Schottland. Da habe ich meine Facharbeit geschrieben. Es ist auch viel Irland. Es ist hauptsächlich Schottland. Ich bin mir relativ sicher, dass Nordirland und Irland massive Probleme haben. Glaubensmässig. Entschuldigung mal. Ich muss meine historische Kriminalität wiederherstellen. Ja, aber Donny und Steiner werden es ein richtig cooler Name. Ich dachte mir erst mal so, heisst kein Mensch. Und dann dachte ich mir, okay, das ist schon immer ein ganz cooler Name. Und du klingst wie so eine Figur aus einer Serie oder einem Roman oder so. Ich glaube dir gar nicht, dass du ein echter Mensch bist. Und du hast für mich auch so eine fantastische Qualität. Du bist irgendwie zum Beispiel, ich finde, es ist immer so wie so ein Riss in der Realität, wo so diese kosmische Narrative so ein bisschen durchscheint. Zum Beispiel kennst du Raoul Krauthausen, das ist dieser behinderte Radiomoderator, der im Rollstuhlsitzung ganz klein ist, und da habe ich mal so eine Reportage über den gesehen und der hat einen Pfleger und der heisst Alan Hunt, wo ich mir dachte, wenn das nicht ein Superheld ist nachts, wenn du Alan Hunt heisst, dann musst du nachts einfach ein Superheld sein, das ist so ein cooler Name, Alan Hunt. Alan Hunt und Donny O'Sullivan, die Abenteuer ist. Donny O'Sullivan, wo ich mir dachte, das ist einfach ein Superheld, das passt einfach genau rein. Und bei Donny O'Sullivan dachte ich mir auch so, das ist so wie ein Name, den sich ein Drehbuchautor ausgedacht hat.
Ja, ich sehe aber gerade diese Superhelden-Story im Sinne von Alan Hunt und Donny O'Sullivan.
Du bist ja der Robin.
So ein Open, wo wir durch die Straßen rennen und dann geht die erste Folge los und wir sind einfach online nur so Helden.
Wir sind nur so für World of Warcraft, so Trolle, die Leute hingehen in so Sachen schenken.
Schamane und Krieger.
Entweder das und Donny O'Sullivan stirbt in der ersten Folge, den tragischen Tod und so, dann ist nur noch Ellen Hand am Start. Er stickt am Qualface. Nee, keine Ahnung, also ich will euch nicht den Wind aus... Ich finde das sehr super, diese Ode gerade an meinen Armen. Mir ist gerade aufgefallen, ich muss mir übrigens unbedingt vornehmen, nicht mehr so zu reagieren, wenn jemand so etwas Liebes sagt, um meinen Namen so zu reagieren, und sagen, mhm, ja. Ja, ist mir auch schon aufgefallen. Ja, stimmt, ist mir auch schon aufgefallen, ja, kommt zu Punkt, so war das gar nicht so gemeint. Ne, aber tatsächlich, O'Sullivan ist tatsächlich in Irland halt wie, also wie Meyer oder so in Deutschland und das Donny ist ja eine Abkürzung halt, ne, also es ist ja nicht, in meiner Geburtsurkunde steht ja nicht Donny, sondern Donnerker, also richtig ausgesprochen, Donnerker, das ist ein irischer Name und das ist, in Ir wird ja quasi auch noch, eigentlich als erste Amtssprache, offiziell ist ja Gaelisch sozusagen. Ich weiß, ich trage einen Dublin-Pull, ich weiß alles über Irland. Und das ist gelische Sprache und das heisst eigentlich, wenn man es wortwörtlich übersetzen würde, hiesse das Dennis. Ah, uncool. So, sind wir da, haben wir jetzt fast aufgemacht, super uncool. Aber ich wurde schon immer einfach Donny genannt, also das ist ganz normal, dass man in Irland, Leute, die Donnecke heißen werden, immer Donny genannt einfach, das ist so wie bei Dominic Dommi oder so und dann genau. Basti. Aber wie bist du hierher gekommen? Flo, bei Flo und sie mit dem Flugzeug. Bist du mit einem Sullivan gefahren? So, ähm, ich dachte, wenn Leute sagen, ich bin ausgewandert, klingt das immer für mich so. Ausgewandert meinst du? Ausgewandert, salivandert. Passt nicht so gut. Aber ausgewandert klingt immer so, als ob man diesen Stock mit diesem Tuch hinten dran hat. Mit diesem Beutel, den man nur filmen kann. Und so einer Karre mit so einem ... Mit Pferden. Ja, ja, und es klingt immer so, dass man wirklich mit diesem Stock und diesem Beutel hinten dran losfährt. Lumpensack. Heißt das so, Lumpensack? Ist das das Wort Lumpensack? Lumpensack. Und so ein Brot, was man irgendwie eingepackt hat in so Papier. So Lämpersbrot. Ja, genau, genau, eins zu eins. Und genau so habe ich das mit dem Kopf, wenn das jemand sah, ich bin ausgewandert. Ich habe mal zwei Tage gesehen, die auf der Walz waren. Da kennen sie so Handwerker, bevor die Meister machen. Ja, mit so Schmackhosen und so. Genau, da müssen die einmal durchs ganze Land laufen oder so, da müssen verschiedene Aufträge erfüllen, einen Drachen erschlagen, eine Jungfrau retten und so und so so Sachen machen und da habe ich gerade studiert und da sassen wir in so einem Café und dann kamen die halt, haben sich so vor das Café gestanden, haben dann ihren Spruch aufgesagt und dann sollte denen jeder was geben und so und dann haben irgendwie der Kaffeebesitzer hat denen einen Kaffee ausgegeben und der Bäcker hat ihnen dann Brot gegeben und wir, und das fand ich damals so schön, weil es wieder so eine Kinderfabel ist, wir haben damals Philosophie studiert und wir Philosophen und dann haben die sich zu uns gesetzt und wir haben dann eine Stunde mit denen diskutiert über Moral und Erkenntnistheorie und so. Boah, schnarche so ungut! Ja, es war mega schein, aber ich finde das ist wieder so eine Kinderfabel. Das fände total geil an. Die Philosophen geben ihm Weisheit und der Bäckermacher gibt ihm Brot und der Banker gibt ihm Brot und so. War es nicht der Beispiele, dass die, das ist einfach dumme Kinder sind, die haben einfach Scheiss erzählt. Ich finde ja wahnsinnig interessant, dass du Philosophie studiert hast, das wusste ich auch nicht. So richtig ernsthaft durchgezogen? Ein Semester oder so. Ne, warte mal, die Zuschauer sehen mein Gesicht, ich meine das jetzt wirklich tatsächlich ohne Gag so, weil es gibt ja viele Leute, die sich ja, Philosophie ist ja gerne mal so ein Studium, wo sich Leute so einschreiben halt so. Also ne, ich habe das schon gerne studiert. Hast du richtig so kannt und so gerade so das? Ja, ja, aber ich habe dann nach zweieinhalb Semestern abgebrochen, weil Frank Elstner mich angerufen hat und gesagt hat, ob ich nicht Moderator werden will. Da habe ich dann gesagt, ja, aber er so knallert. War so ein rotes Telefon mit so einer Wehscheibe. Ja, ja. So ein Lichtgebruchter, so ein Passant. Der Commissioner ruft an. So eine Stange runtergerutscht, weil er war bereit einfach. Und er war nackt dabei. Frank Elstner ist nackt, eine Stange runtergerutscht und hat gesagt, aber hier können wir es ganz kurz hier beenden.
Also tatsächlich ist diese Frage sehr berechtigt, wenn man sich mal den Lebensanlauf anschaut. Oh, Lebensanlauf, da ist gerade ein Versprecher passiert, der aber supergut ist eigentlich, ein Lebensanlauf. Ja, das stimmt. Ist das ganze Leben nicht nur ein Anlauf? Ja, genau. Get a room! Also, was haben wir? Bad Boy in der Schule haben wir, wie behandelst du Frauen, Snooker-Gag haben wir auch. Bad Boy, Snooker-Gag.
Der erste große Nieuwe haben noch einen. Genau, was wir noch sagen wollten, wir müssen mal ein bisschen was Organisatorisches abklappern. Und zwar, da kannst du ja einfach Gags oder Geräusche einwerfen, je nachdem. Und zwar wollen wir demnächst haben wir einjähriges Jubiläum. Das Podcast-Ufo gibt es ein Jahr lang. Wir haben im Dezember 2014 angefangen. Und als Jubiläum zum Einjährigen wollten wir eine Best-of-Folge machen, so nochmal die besten Bits, damit die Leute, die auch neu einsteigen und ein bisschen hören. Und jetzt, Augenzwinkern, auch für euch vielleicht ein kleiner Tipp, wir wollen die Community natürlich einbinden und haben vor, dass ihr uns eure besten, eure favorite moments schickt einfach mal in in Wort, quasi was euch am besten gefallen hat davon, dass wir das zusammenschneiden können. Also einfach irgendwelche, die ihr besonders gut fandet oder wo ihr euch noch besonders daran erinnern kann. Wollen wir da nicht so eine Umfrage machen? Also ich fände es gar nicht, wollen wir das komplett demokratisch machen. Ich habe das Gefühl, die Folge mit mir wird einfach nochmal gepostet, einfach so, und nutzt das so den Highlight von allen Sendungen. Nur deine Teilen, nur deine Spur. Genau. Nur deine Spur. So inzwischenzwischen einfach Musik. Das heißt, falls ihr irgendwie Lieblingsstories habt, die ihr immer wieder euch gerne anhört oder einfach die euch in Erinnerung geblieben, postet sie einfach in Schrift und irgendwie, völlig egal, und wir schneiden dann was cooles zusammen. Und dann wird das, glaube ich, eine ganz gute Folge, mit dem wir uns dann auch bewerben wollen bei Gäste in der Geisterbahn. Einfach mal so ein kleines als Showread. In den Atempausen, dass wir dann vielleicht kurz zu hören sind. Das war Punkt eins. Punkt zwei, wir haben ja von euch schon eine ganze Menge Kindheitsstories bekommen, die Geschichten, die ihr als Kinder geschrieben habt. Vielen Dank dafür, wir werden in der nächsten Folge darauf eingehen. Was ist das eigentlich für eine Rubrik gerade, die wir an der Tat haben? Sehr ernst. Sehr ernst. Organisatorisch ist es einfach. Mein Gott, man muss auch mal ein bisschen... Warte mal, ich frage mich gerade die ganze Zeit, ob das jetzt quasi so, wenn das jetzt, wenn das läuft, diese Rubrik, die du gerade so schön anmoderierst, was du ja natürlich bei Freikern so gelernt hast, kommt dann so klimpernde Musik drunter und das ist so ein geiler Reggae-Song, der ein bisschen entspannter ist.
Jetzt mach bitte nicht so coole Musik gerade drunter.
Aber verklag uns ohne Scheiße, wenn wir jetzt das abspiegeln, deine Musik hier.
Kann ich nicht, ist alles ohne GEMA.
Ist ohne GEMA, ist GEMA freie Musik?
Ja, eigentlich schon, ja.
Du rissst für den Player auf Spotify nichts? Nee. Ist das nicht das Unklugste, was du jemals gemacht hast? Ja. Das ist doch der Renner in Clubs. Ich will einfach was wiedergeben. Willst du die Menschheit was wiedergeben? Nee, erzähl ich dir ein andermal, es ist mega kompliziert, sich da anzumelden und so irgendwie zu vorn zu machen. Also, wir wollen in der nächsten Folge nochmal auf die Kindheitsstories eingehen, und deswegen schickt weiter Storys ein, vielen Dank für euch, die schon eingesehlt haben. In der nächsten Folge nehmen wir die alle auf. Wir haben euch nicht vergessen. So, dritter und letzter Punkt des Organisatoren. Es gibt das Podcast UFO, T-Shirts zu bestellen. Was? Da wollen Sie noch gar nichts von. Ja, jetzt noch nicht, aber sobald die Folge ausgestrahlt wird, dann wahrscheinlich schon. Da steht dann Dublin Irland drauf. Wir fangen erst mal mit einem Lame-Motiv an, und dann, wenn die es nicht gut verkauft, dann kommen noch coolere Motive. Kleblatt zum Beispiel, das Gesicht von Dollywood einfach als wie er damals... Von Dollywood bin ich jetzt. Dollywood, Donneka, wie schreibt man das überhaupt? Dono-Kern? Also jetzt halt doch mal die Fresse, ganz ohne das Tor ist. Ihr könnt beide T-Shirts bestellen, ja aber lass uns das mal hinter uns bringen, damit wir gleich weiter. Macht das bei O-Nit-Tor ist okay. Also, ihr könnt T-Shirts bestellen und macht das fleissig und wir werden allerdings verposten, wie wir es auch können und das wird super gut.
Und falls ihr eigene Motivideen habt, irgendwelche Dinge, irgendwelche Running Gags, irgendwelche Catchphrases aus der Sendung, irgendwelche visuellen Dinge, ob es jetzt Stefans Alien auf der Bank ist, ob es einer meiner Träume ist, die ihr natürlich auch selber illustrieren könnt. Wenn ihr Bock habt, selber ein Bild zu malen, kann es sein, dass ihr die irgendwann auf einem unserer T-Shirts wiederfindet. Wir sind froh über jeden Input. Das war das Video der Tote. Bis zurück zum Podcast. Wow, wow, wow, wow, wow! Aber jetzt erst mal ihr. Erst mal einen Booster. Hast du schon einen Booster probiert eigentlich? Es pusht dich. Nee, ich bin ja kein so ein Energy Drink-Mensch. Ja, wenn du dich fragst, warum wir immer auf so einem Gag-Niveau sind, wo wir sagen, wo die Messeleite schon sehr hoch ist, weil wir sind schon Comedy-Masterminds, liegt das nicht daran, dass wir einfach wahnsinnig gut sind, sondern auch weil wir wahnsinnig aufgeputscht sind mit Booster Energydrink. Warte mal, habt ihr echt so einen Booster, habt ihr so einen Vertrag oder? Booster Energydrink. Ach stimmt ja, ja, ja, klar, jetzt macht er, ja, ja, ja, ja. Booster. Booster liebe ich. Booster ist der absolute Hammer. Booster ist der absolute Hammer. Da muss auch ein bisschen was reinm ja absolut Hammer. Es gibt ja Leute, die gehen ja abends, so gerade in Berlin, die gehen gerne irgendwie weg und lange feiern. Berlin? Dann irgendwie Drogen oder nehmen, ne, brauche ich nicht, brauche Booster. Booster, brauche einen geilen Booster. Boost your life. Booster.com, da sind jetzt noch die neuen Sorten drauf. Ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, dass ich da Booster.com habe. Booster.biz oder so, ich weiß nicht, was das ist. Booster.fail. Äh, wir haben ja gerade über ... Ganz kurz, wo wir grad bei Internetseiten sind, die von Gästenliste Geistermann gefällt mir sehr gut. Und da würde ich kurz mal fragen, ob ihr uns den Quelltext leicht kopieren könntet. Weil unsere Red ist wirklich nicht cool, Flo hat sich schon mal aus Spaß gelöscht, einfach mal, weil sie so aufgeregt hat. Und wer hat die denn bei euch gemacht, warst du das? Also das hat der Herm gemacht, ich bin ja kein Webdesigner. Auch so ein Name, ne? Nils mit Z, crazy, Donny, crazy, Herm, what? Mega. Viele Leute sagen ja, dass da der Erfolg ja überhaupt erst herrührt. Also nicht das, was wir sagen, sondern weil wir so crazy Namen haben. Das gefällt den Leuten im Alltag einfach so. Dass es einfach so Leute sind, die komische Namen haben, dass sie auch irgendwie einen Podcast machen können. Was ist denn dein Nickname, so bei Spielen oder online, hast du so ein Nickname, den du nimmst? Long Don. Ich fand übrigens, nee, ich hab dann tatsächlich immer das, oh das ist aber super peinlich, ey. Ich weiß, deswegen frag ich ja nicht. Warte mal, gibt's überhaupt einen coolen Nickname? Ich glaube nicht, nein. Eigentlich nicht, also ich hab tatsächlich, weil ich ja bei Mucke machen hies ich ja immer, oder heiss ich ja Dubsen und eigentlich ...
Dein aktuelles Album heisst, Monday is the new Sunday.
Das steht ja mal dahinter wegen Son of Dublin sozusagen und ich hab mal mit Dubs-Musik angefangen, also richtig so Reggae-Dub-Musik und so, das ist ja schon ewig alt so, ne?
Irgendwann, wie das halt so ist, ist er halt so hängen geblieben, ne?
So, und jetzt kommt der Oberpeinliche in den Namen immer so, Dubsanizer.
The Dubsanizer!
Wow!
Und dann bei allen Ladies immer, you are Dubsanized.
You just got Dubsanized.
Get ready to Dubsanize!
Get ready to get Dubsanized!
Dubsalicious!
You're Dubsanized!
Ich weiss, es ist super peinlich.
Sehr unangenehm.
Aber Moment, Florian hat auch einen super peinlichen Nicknamen, den er bei seinen Videospielen zum Beispiel benutzt.
Videospiel aus Ich weiss, es ist super peinlich. Sehr unangenehm. Aber Moment, Florian hat auch einen super peinlichen Nicknamen, den er bei seinen Videospielen zum Beispiel benutzt. Videospiel, auch ein wahnsinnig uncooler Begriff. Er heisst Nifty. Finde ich aber nicht so doof. Kann man mal sagen? Nifty ist in Ordnung. Och man, Leute, ich bin hier bulletproof, keine Chance. Nifty ist cool. Das freut von mir ab. Wir hatten übrigens in der Schule, fällt mir gerade ein das, das, das, das, das, das, das, das, das, das, das, das, das, das, das, das, das, das, das, das, das, das, das, das, das, das, das, das, das, das, das, das, das, das, das, das, das, das, das, das, das, das, das, das, das, das, das, das, das, das, das, das, das, das, das, das, das, das, das, das, das, das, das, das, das, das, das, das, das, das, das, das, das, das, das, das, das, das, das, das, das, das, das, das, das, das, das, das, das, das, das, das, das, das, das, das, das, das, das, das, das, das, das, das, das, das, das, das, das, das, das, das, das, das, das, das, das, das, das, das, das, das, das, das, das, das, das, das, das, das, das, das, das, das, das, das, das, das, das, das, das, das, das, das, das, das, das, das, das, das, das, das, das, das, das, das, das, das, das, das, das, hast irgendwas mit Agen gesagt und ich war gerade auf, wir hatten einen in, ich hoffe, er hört das jetzt nicht, obwohl, er hat auch damals drüber gelacht, wir hatten halt so einen Typ in der Stufe, der heisst Hagen, so ne, aber wir hatten, irgendwann war es so krass, wir hatten so viele Wortspiele mit dem, einfach Krankenhagen, Hagen-Darm-Grippe, wenn er krank war oder keine Ahnung, da liegt echt was im Hagen und sowas. Das war nicht so furchtbar schlimm. Wir hatten dann so einen Ordner, wisst ihr noch, früher hat man doch quasi so einen Ordner gehabt ab der Oberstufe, weil er sehr kunder war, als Hefte zu haben. Ja, ja. Und da hat man ja links immer alles so reingeschrieben, so Sachen so irgendwie so, wenn du neben deinem Kumpel saß, da hat er auch so ein bisschen was gekritzelt und sowas. Unbeschriftlich. Ich hatte so einordentlich, da war alles voll mit Hagen-Gags. Wir hatten einen kompletten, also ich fand wirklich, die komplette Seite war nur voll mit Hagen-Watt. Sehr schön, das liegt ein bisschen schwer im Hagen. Ja, genau wie Löschblätter. Wir kamen dann auch immer zu dem an und so, ich weiß nicht, da hast du Hagen-Darmgrippe, irgendwas liegt mir total schwer im Hagen. Ich glaube, wir brauchen einen kranken Hagen. Ich weiß nicht. Sehr gut, in zwei Stunden so weiter. Den Gag hast du vor Hagen gebracht, Mann, ey. So die ganzen Te Zeit. Das finde ich ganz geil. Tatsächlich erinnere ich mich noch, in der vierten Klasse oder wirklich sehr früh gab es ein Mädchen aus unserer Klasse, deren Talent war es, zu jedem Namen irgendeine beleidigende Konnotation zu finden und er hat alle fertig gemacht. Also irgendjemand, zu jedem Namen hat sie eines gefunden und niemand konnte ihren Namen irgendwie fertig machen. Wie hieß sie denn? Das kann ich nicht sagen, weil ich gleich noch den Nachnamen sage. Larschklappel. Keiner kam noch. Carina Titler. Genau, Carina Larschklappel. Und dann, man ist ja so stetig reifer geworden und die Sexualität kam irgendwann näher. Und irgendwann, weiss ich noch, das war ein von uns in der Klasse, hat es plötzlich Ping gemacht, die Pubertät war da. Ständer bekommen. Und plötzlich war alles da und ihr Nachname war Herma. Und plötzlich hieß sie Sperma, Sperma und plötzlich war der Bann gebrochen wie so ein Untotenherr, wo der Anführer stirbt und alle klappen so um. Und plötzlich hat sie niemanden mehr beleidigt, alle, weil der Fluch war gebrochen und alle waren frei. Sie war gebrochen und hat die Schule gewechselt aus Mobbing. Schule gewechselt. Ja genau, und sie ist einfach so eine tragische Geschichte. Das klappst du jetzt halt. Genau. Ja gut. Stille. Stille. Das ist nachher so einer guten Anekdote, man überlegt. Einfach nur mal so kurz zurückdenken an die Anekdote. Das fehlt uns so tage. Ich schreib mir auch mal was wirken lassen, einfach mal kurz. Schweigen können, muss man auch. Schweigen können, gemeinsam schweigen können. Man sagt ja, du hast die Richtige gefunden oder den Richtigen oder was auch immer, wenn man gemeinsam schweigen kann. Pulp Fiction. Hast du das wirklich in Pulp Fiction gesagt? Ja, tatsächlich die Essenszene im Jackrabbits Slim Whatever Diner, ich weiß nicht genau wie es heißt. Hast du auch ein Plakat von Pulp Fiction in deiner Serie? Exakt, ganz kurz, also du bist schon Designer, du bist schon im weitesten Sinne im Designkonzept. Jetzt will er noch mal festnageln. Du bist aber schon Designer, oder? Ich bin ja auch so krass durcheinander. Also wenn wirklich jemand irgendwann die Folge angucken will, wer sich über mich informieren will, dann habe ich gehabt. Du musst zwei Sachen noch mal aufschreiben. Ich glaube, kein Mensch will sich über dich informieren. Ja, das stimmt auch wieder. Aber du bist doch so eine Art Designer, also du würdest dich weitinen als Grafiker zeigen. Ich bin, ja, nee, also pass auf, ich kann es ganz kurz erklären. Ich bin, habe Abi gemacht 2004 in Tübingen, wie gesagt, bin aber dann schon relativ, also in dem Jahr noch nach Berlin gezogen, also seit zehn Jahren jetzt in Berlin, weil ich ja kein CV machen musste oder Wehrdienst oder so, weil ich ja keine deutsche Staatsbürgerschaft habe, auch nach wie vor nicht habe, weil man es irgendwie nicht braucht, was übrigens manchmal, ja doch, ich habe die irische Staatsbürgerschaft. Und da musstest du da nicht irgendwie? Nee, das ist aber weird, dass man das nicht braucht. Ja, manchmal ist es auch weird, gerade wenn ich irgendwie zu Bürgerämtern muss, mich ummelden, von keinem Frieden auf Kreuzberg oder sowas, dann kommt auch immer so, ja, dann sage ich so, ja, ja, ich habe ja gar keinen deutschen Pass, wie, sie haben keinen deutschen Pass, wie, sie haben keinen deutschen Pass, wie, ja, nee, was machen Sie denn hier? Da ist die Tür mein Lieber. Da ist die Tür, hau ab, du Scheiße. Aber ich konnte nicht auf Englisch vollquatschen. Aber da fällt mir gerade ein, das war dann lustig, ich war mal in so einem Amt und dann, ich habe ja mit meinem Namen immer das Problem mit dem Apostroph, weil halt so O, Apostroph, S, ne, so. Und die meisten Leute machen anstatt dem, wirklich auf der Tastatur dem Apostroph, machen die quasi das, was auf dem E dann so hängen bleibt, auf dem O und so, weil da wird aus dem O quasi so ein O mit Accent, genau so. Und da ich das aber weiss, genau, das ist wirklich so wie bei Pokémon, und da ich das aber weiss, guck ich halt immer dann mega nerdig auf die Tastatur, wenn ich halt irgendwo in einem Amp bin, wo so eine dicke Berlinerin sitzt, die so eh gestresst ist den ganzen Tag und guck da immer drauf, ne mittlerweile bin ich da doch zurückgelehnt, ich hab das so im A hab das so im Auge. Neulich war das halt, das war vor einem halben Jahr oder so, war das wieder so und dann fängt, ich seh schon, die macht's falsch und das wird im System halt nicht funktionieren und so weiter. Wenn ich dann nachher mal wiederkomme, dann passt das nicht und so. Dann sag ich so, ja, ich kann Ihnen auch helfen, ich kann Ihnen sagen, jetzt bleiben Sie mal auf Ihrer Seite, so geht das hier nicht, so geht das hier Jahre erst. So, und ich so, okay, alles klar. Und dann dachte ich mir so, war ich auch sauer auf sie, weil sie so schnippisch war, und ich dachte, okay, dann soll sie halt, dann halb ich ihr jetzt auch nicht so. Ich war sauer. Und dann ging das aber ewig, und dann original, wirklich wie in so einem schlechten Sketch, sagt so, Sabine, kannst du mal kommen, ich krieg das Ding nicht ins System rin, und dann kommt eine andere dazu, dann sitzen die beide über der Tastatur und wollen diese Apostel finden, und ich darf denen nicht helfen, ich darf nicht sagen, hey, entschuldigen Sie, ich kann Ihnen da sagen, jetzt bleiben mal sitzen, wir kriegen das schon hin, dass ich nicht höre Ohrfärbe habe. Wir kriegen das hin. Das war ganz schlimm auf jeden Fall. Das mal als Anekdote dazu. Ich bin stehen geblieben bei 2004, Abi nach Berlin. Wir waren ja Designer, ich wollte dich doch festmachen. Genau, und dann habe ich eine Ausbildung gemacht als Mediengestalter, also quasi bei einer Firma gearbeitet, übrigens Magix, die den Magix Music Maker machen, was vielleicht der eine oder andere kennt. Wow, geil! ist übrigens die Software, mit der ich jetzt mal der erste Mal Musik produziert habe. Das ist eigentlich eine ganz coole... Dein aktuelles Album heißt, man da ist der New Sunday jetzt erhältlich auf iTunes und Spotify. Sketchy. Ne, da habe ich eine Ausbildung, ganz normal betriebliche Ausbildung gemacht, drei Jahre lang, also quasi 40 Stunden Woche da sitzen, dann für mich daraus gelernt in diesen drei Jahren. Ich möchte nie in meinem Leben einen Bürojob machen, weil es einfach ein... Sich einhängt. Aber warum? Man kann das Büro einrichten, du kannst es da machen, du kannst dir einen Part-Piction-Paket aufhängen, du kannst dir diese Kugeln, diese Newton-Kugeln aufhängen. Aber ich würde es auch gerne betonen, dass ich das jetzt nicht so generalisieren möchte, also wirklich jetzt mal, also jeder ist ja anders so und ich habe halt für mich voll gemerkt, nach so zwei, drei Jahren, also gerade im dritten Jahr war das furchtbar, da jeden Tag da hinzugehen und dann quasi Zeit zu verschwenden, weil viele Leute machen das ja auch wirklich, dass du im Büro sitzt und eigentlich gar nicht arbeitest. Also wirklich acht Stunden da sitzt und irgendwann, damals gab es ja noch nicht so krass Facebook, das heißt ich habe so ein anderes Online-Spiel gespielt, O-Game, Schülerfacett. Naja und man sitzt halt wirklich da und dann fühlt sich einfach scheiße, du kommst nach Hause, bist trotzdem müde, obwohl du nur da sass, acht Stunden lang. Und ich hatte richtig so Spiegelsysteme gebaut, weil ich immer so andere Sachen gemacht habe, außer Arbeit, so rumgesurft und so, dass mein Chef, wenn der von hinten kommt, dass ich sehe, wann der kommt, dann den Chef wechseln kann. Ich habe also quasi mehr Energie reingesteckt, nicht zu arbeiten, als wirklich zu arbeiten. Das finde ich so eine gute Sache, aber dass man Jobs machen kann, wo man nicht arbeitet und es fällt nicht so doll auf. Ja, genau, deswegen sagt Tia, das ist ja Typsache, mich hat das ja fertig gemacht. Jeder ist anders, schönes Zitat von Donny O'Sullivan, jeder ist anders. Jeder ist anders, gibt es auch ein T-Shirt jetzt. Ja, mit Podcast-Ufologen und Buster drunter. Ne, und deswegen ist mir auch aufgefallen, ich habe jetzt am Wochenende... Du hast ja gefragt, warte, du hast ja gefragt, ob ich Designer bin. Ganz kurz, es dauert eine Minute... Ganz kurz immer einmal ab. am Wochenende habe ich eine Bar, musste ich zapfen. Und das finde ich so furchtbar, weil du halt kontinuierlich arbeiten musst. Und wenn du nicht arbeitest, merken das Leute, weil sie aggressiv werden. Die wollen was haben. Und es ist bei mir noch viel schlimmer als bei allem anderen. Stimmt. Aber ich könnte niemals einen Job machen, wo Leute merken, dass man nicht arbeitet gerade. So als Kellner, wo du den Hass dann aber auch direkt zurückbekommst. So, wenn du das nicht machst, dann kippt das ganze System um. Und im Büro, wenn man das nicht mehr haben kann, ist das doch total grossartig. Ja, okay, das ist tatsächlich ein guter Vergleich. Oder Autor für den Fernsehsendern. So gesehen, ja genau. Glaube ich, weiß ich nicht. Dann einfach bei Brainstormings immer mitmachen und nachher sagen, ja, war meine Idee, aber nur im Freundeskreis. Ja, klar, ja, ja, klar. Aber du weißt schon, das war eine meine Idee. Die Bauchbind ist von mir. Ja, die ist von mir. Ne, um das kurz abzuschliessen, ich habe dann die Ausbildung gemacht und habe dann angefangen, war dann halt irgendwie fertig, nicht übernommen worden, aber ich habe es auch nicht darauf angelegt und habe dann bei MTV angefangen, so ein Praktikum zu machen und so. Damals war das ja noch so halb cool. Und dann, um deine Frage zu beantworten wegen Designer, habe ich mich 2009, war das, beworben auf die UdK, nee, 2008 war das, beworben auf die UdK, also quasi Universitätskünste in Berlin, um halt einen Designstudiengang zu machen für Grafikdesign. Damals war ich noch voll der, auch so richtig nerdiger Grafikdesigner. Ich wollte, das war mein Leben so, ich wollte geile Grafiken machen und irgendwie Poster gestalten und so. Helvetica, Ball, Cousine, so typos. Genau, so den ganzen Quatsch halt so. Und die kennen mich nach wie vor, leider Gottes, aus.
Und ich hab dann, und das Geile ist, ich hab damals bei meiner Bewerbung, bei der Udeka, bei meiner ersten Bewerbung bin ich ja nicht genommen worden.
Da musst du halt so eine Mappe hinschicken und so, dann bist du eingeladen.
Und die haben mich nicht mal eingeladen zu diesem zweiten Ding, sondern die haben mir einen Brief geschickt.
Das hängt bei mir, eingerahmt im Dings.
Da steht einfach als Begründung, kein künstlerisches Talent feststellbar. Wir haben lange gesucht, aber wir haben einfach keines gefunden. Das steht wirklich da, das war natürlich, aber im Nachhinein betreut ist ja so eine automatische, da bewerben sich halt irgendwie jedes Jahr, irgendwie tausend Leute. Naja, das hast du dir eingeredet, es hängt bei dem bestimmt auch ein Bild von dir irgendwie so drin, irgendwie auch eingerahmt in deren Büro. Naja, ich habe aber im nächsten Jahr mich ja wieder beworben, bin angenommen worden, habe ja jetzt meinen Abschluss gemacht, mit einer 1,0. Das künstlerische Talent kam mir dann wohl irgendwann. Du bist bei denen im System das Beispielbild für kein künstlerisches Talent vorhanden, die fünf verschiedenen Fälle, warum man abhebt. So wenn es so aussieht, genau. Genau wie bei so Freizeitparks, wo so Gesichter aufhängen, so, ihn bitte nicht reinlassen, die Hausverbot haben, so, ablehnen, ausrufezeichen. Ne, worauf ich hinaus wollte, eigentlich nur, also es hat mir jetzt ein bisschen zu lange dauert eigentlich dafür, dass für diesen leichten Gag, den ich jetzt anstehen wollte. Also es war eine gute Story, aber es hätte kürzer sein können. Ja, aber jetzt habe ich ja mal erzählt, was ich mache, ich meine. Ja, ist doch gut, für alle Leute, die zuhören und dich kennenlernen wollen. Ne, aber ich wollte sagen, euer Logo ist ja jetzt nicht so geil. Aber du bist doch Grafikdesigner, ich wollte dich jetzt eh drauf festnageln, deswegen. Du hast eben gesagt, dass du Grafiken geil findest. Ja, das Logo hab ich gemacht. Aber gestern ist die Geisterbahn, hätte man sich ja jetzt theoretisch mehr Mühe geben können. Du hättest jetzt so eine geile Geisterbahn designen können, die kommt und wieder fährt. alle Illustraturen. Nö, ich hab da so ein paar Entwürfe gemacht und den Jungs in die Runde geschickt, genauso haben wir das entschieden wie mit dem Namen und so. Bisschen Grailsom. Und genau, wir haben so ein bisschen Whatsapp gebranct. Hast Farben vorgeschlagen, und dann wollten sie alle halt alles schwarz-weiss haben. Genau, hab da natürlich alles durchdekliniert in fünfzigtausend verschiedenen Schriftarten, ihr kennt das, das war so ein Durchlaufprozess, Maria musste das ja auch abnehmen bei uns alles, ne? dann ist die Freitag nicht da, dann muss man den Montag warten und so. Und dann war das so ein Schnellschuss. Der war nicht so schlecht. Ich hab den nicht gehört, der war ich so selber. Ich hab gesagt, Nils muss dringend abnehmen. Nils muss dringend abnehmen. Aber mein Gott, er wird nicht besser, Leute, ich kann ihn noch dreimal sagen. Aber ich fand den ganz gut eigentlich jetzt so. Ja, okay. Ähm, nö, ich finde, ich finde es okay eigentlich. Das ist okay. Das ist okay, aber es ist nicht Grafiker okay. Nö, genau, es sollte so ein News... Ich glaube, ich glaube... Wo genau willst du damit hinstellen? Ich will die nur fertig machen. Es ist für mich kein künstlerisches Talent erkennbar. Ja. Aber ist es nicht die Aufgabe von gutem Design, nicht aufzufallen immer, sondern sich irgendwie sehr bescheiden zu sein, zurückzunehmen, sodass wenn du denkst, ich höre mir den Podcast gerne an, dann hat er eigentlich schon alles richtig gemacht, weil es nicht auffällt.
Also ist nicht Design vom Prinzip her eigentlich die bescheidenste Kunstform, weil sie sich immer in andere Dimensionen eingliedern muss? Nö, ich glaube auch, dass du den Begriff Design so ein bisschen lapidar benutzt. Design ist ja ein mega generischer Begriff, das kann ja alles mögliche sein. Ich glaube, was du jetzt gerade meinst, ist tatsächlich wirklich spezifisch Grafikdesign.
Und beim Grafikdesign kann man das so nicht sagen, finde ich, weil ich glaube, Grafikdesign muss und kann sich sehr gerne zurücknehmen, kann aber auch offensiv nach vorne gehen. Das kommt, also es klingt jetzt echt wie so ein Phrasenschwein-Spruch, beim Grafiker-Stammtisch müsste ich jetzt zehn Euro dafür ins Phrasenschwein werfen. Aber jeder Mensch ist anders. Ja, jeder Mensch ist anders. Design hat ja auch auch oft eine sehr grosse ... Ich bin voll der Politiker-Film auch. Jeder wird bei uns immer so philosophisch immer. Auch Nils Burgelberg hat ja Sachen rausgehauen, die alle rausgeschnitten wurden. Aber Design hat ja oft eine sehr starke Immersion. Okay, jetzt hast du ein Fremdwort gesagt, was ich nicht verstehe. Immersion? Wir haben aber ganz kurz am Anfang im Vorgespräch, in dem Gespräch, wo Flore ... Hast du einen Gag gemachtag gemacht, den würde ich gerne nochmal machen. Warte, die will ich etwas erzählen. Ganz kurz, wenn die Zuhörer, das wisst ihr ja gar nicht, wenn man beim Podcast-UFO eingeladen wird, das ist wie bei Markus Lanz, man ist in so einem Raum, wird geschminkt, geht halt irgendwie so, warum auch immer. Man fragt sich noch so, warum Maske, wir sind doch nur, ah ja, das ist einfach für dich. Und dann kommen die Jungs einer nach dem anderen Spendengelder ein. Also erst kommt Florian hin rein und begrüsst dich so mega nett und ist halt so, hey, keine Sorge, wir machen das, das wird richtig geil und so. Ich stelle die und die Frage, hey, nicht wundern und so. Und dann hast du kurz Ruhe und dann kommt Stefan rein und der ist dann vorher so, ja, der sieht ein bisschen scheiße aus, kannst du da noch mehr was drauf machen und so. So ein bisschen Good Cop, Bad Cop mässig. Ja, genau. Ja, genau so ist das. Und ich habe mich jetzt gefragt, um dich auch wieder in so eine Ecke zu drängen, in die du hoffentlich nicht rauskommst, habt ihr so eine Art Sendeablauf, also bei bei Gästenliste Geisterbahn, ihr seid drei Leute. Wenn wir zu dritt sind, wir haben mit Gästen oft ein Problem, dass wir andauernd irgendwie reinreden, weil wir nicht wissen, wohin das Gespräch gerade führt. Und es ist wirklich auch immer so, man weiß nicht genau, ist es der Weg jetzt sicher, den man jetzt geht mit der Anekdote, wo führt hin? Gibt's Abzweigungen? Wer geht welche Abzweigungen?
Das ist wie so ein Roller-Causse, right?
Also ein Podcast ist ein Roller-Causse. Nee, das ist genau das Gegenteil von einem Roller-Causse.
Also quasi genau wie das, wie du gerade erzählst.
Ich weiß selber nicht, wo der Satz endet, den ich anfange.
Aber das habt ihr nicht. Ihr habt schon eine Art Sendeablauf.
Nee, also ich kann es dir ganz klar sagen, wir haben am Anfang angefangen mit,
ich glaube die allererste Folge haben wir,
haben wir wirklich tatsächlich einfach nur quasi von der Energie gelebt, dass wir uns wirklich, wir sehen uns ja wirklich alle zwei Wochen nur, weil wir alle anderen Quarms machen irgendwie und nicht jeden Tag zusammen abhängen, da haben wir wirklich einfach ein bisschen Glück gehabt, es war ja voll so ein Griff ins Blau oder wie das heisst, wie heisst das hier, so ein Griff ins Schlo, wir wussten ja ein, so ein, so ein, so ein, so ein, so ein, so ein, so ein, so ein, so ein, so ein, so ein, so ein, so ein, so ein, so ein, so ein, so ein, so ein, so ein, so ein, so ein, so ein, so ein, so ein, so ein, so ein, so ein, so ein, so ein, so ein, so ein, so ein, so ein, so ein, so ein, so ein, so ein, so ein, so ein, so ein, so ein, so ein, so ein, so ein, so ein, so ein, so ein, so ein, so ein, so ein, so ein, so ein, so ein, so ein, so ein, so ein, so ein, so ein, so ein, so ein, so ein, so ein, so ein, so ein, so ein, so ein, so ein, so ein, so ein, so ein, so ein, so ein, so ein, so ein, so ein, so ein, so ein, so ein, so ein, so ein, so ein, so ein, so ein, so ein, so ein, so ein, so ein, so ein, so ein, so ein, so ein, so ein, so ein, so ein, so ein, so ein, so ein, so ein, so ein, so ein, so ein, so ein, so ein, so ein, so ein, so ein, so ein, so ein, so ein, so ein, so ein, so ein, so ein, so ein, so ein, so ein, so ein, so ein, so ein, so ein, so ein, so ein, so ein, so ein, so ein, so ein, so ein, so ein, so ein, so ein, so ein, so ein, so einuen Daumen. Nee, aber kurz wegen deiner Frage, wegen dem Redaktionsplan.
Wir haben dann tatsächlich nach der zweiten oder dritten Folge schon gesagt,
haben wir so in der WhatsApp-Gruppe einfach gesagt,
jeder sollte mal so ein paar Themen oder Stichworte nennen,
über die er reden will. Und das war dann quasi,
wenn mir irgendeine lustige Story passiert ist,
habe ich dann halt ein Stichwort reingetet, nur für mich als quasi Reminder,
und dann kann ich die Geschichte so erzählen.
Sex, Sex, peinliche Peniswitze. Genau, Podcast-Ufo, Scheisse, stand ganz oft schon. Boring. Und dann haben wir uns einfach so ein bisschen da entlang gehangelt. Aber je länger wir das machen, desto wir haben jetzt auch schon Folgen gehabt, wo wir teilweise gar nicht drauf geguckt haben und einfach ein gutes Gespräch hatten. Und dann einfach das dann so lief. Also wir haben es immer da, wir machen immer so einen Doc, wo wir so Sachen reinschreiben, wo wir denken, dass wir ... Jeder für sich reinschreibt eine Geschichte, die er erzählen möchte, wo er denkt, das ist interessant oder lustig oder was auch immer. Und wenn wir merken im Gespräch, wir kriegen so einen Punkt, wo wir alle so gerade merken, okay, das Gespräch läuft gerade so ein bisschen aus, wir haben jetzt irgendwie keine Energie, auch jetzt so weiter drüber zu reden, dann guckt man halt drauf, hat so als zum Entlanghangeln einfach. Bei uns steht auf dem Doc eigentlich bei jeder Folge nur, wir müssen mehr wie Gäste, Lisse, Geister, Bahn werden. So lustig sein. Das finde ich aber gar nicht. Also wie gesagt, jetzt ohne Geschleim, ich höre mir meinen Podcast total gerne an. Ich finde das eigentlich, was mir ja bei euch gefällt, was wir ja gar nicht so haben, also wo ich jetzt aber nicht sage, dass ich finde, dass wir das brauchen, wir sind ja einfach ganz anders als ihr. Was ich aber bei euch voll mag, ist dieses, vielleicht ist es auch so eine Berufskrankheit, dass ihr supergut und gerne so Sachen, so Gags durchanalysiert irgendwie so. Also einer macht irgendwie einen Gag, der vielleicht ganz gut war. Ich finde das dann wahnsinnig interessant, den so quasi sich darüber weiter zu spinnen, wie man den hätte bringen können. Auseinanderklamysen. Ja, von manchen. Ich habe vor allem neulich eine Vorlesung irgendwie, worum das Prinzip eines Gags erklärt wurde, weil wir irgendwie über so kurze Meldungen, Glossen gesprochen haben oder so.
Und das war, das fand ich total lustig, weil die Erklärung war, dass ein Gag immer so eine Anspannung in einem auslöst und die dann durch die Pointe gelöst wird.
Und dann ging aber, dann war es so eine Kurve quasi, die so hoch ging und dann rapide abfiel.
Aber dann war so eine kleine gestrichelte Linie noch daneben, die weiterging, die Anspannung also weiter analysiert hat. Und dann habe ich gedacht, was heißt das denn? Und dann kam die nächste Folie, dann kam so ein Pfeil auf diese gestrichelte Linie. Das ist ein sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, Publikum. Die sind einfach den Rest ihres Lebens mit der Spannung leben müssen, die Abendschweine. Ich habe mir so eine Crowd vorgestellt, die so einen Gag nicht versteht, aber die ganze Zeit so weiter... Was macht denn der Mann beim Arzt jetzt? Was macht der? So ein riesiger angespanntes, wieso? Es ist einfach so eine sehr angespannte Crowd, Leute, die den Gag nicht verstehen offensichtlich. Und das denke ich mir auch, wenn ich mir unsere Hörer vorstelle, stelle ich mir so eine wahnsinnig angespannte, angespannte Meute vor. Oder einen, den Forward-Medien. Ja, oder einen, diesen einen unserer Hörer, den immer in der U-Bahn sitzt und sich denkt, fuck. Wie sind denn eure Hörer, habt ihr coole Hörer? Ich glaube, wir haben die coolsten Hörer der Welt. Aber kriegt ihr viel Feedback und so, weil wir haben echt ein Problem mit Hörern, dass wir, also wir denken, wir sind coole Typen, aber unsere Hörer sind halt nicht so cool. Und da überlegen wir immer, wo können wir noch coole Hörer abgreifen. Ich glaube ganz arg, das klingt jetzt richtig dumm, aber ich meine, man muss halt ehrlich sein, wir machen uns da tatsächlich gar nicht so eine Gedanken. Ja, aber das kann ich mir nicht vorstellen, weil ihr seid drei auch Rampensäuer. Ich meine, da ist Gilles Bockelberg dabei, da ist ein Herm dabei, da bist du dabei, du hast schon viele andere Sachen, wo du hier bist. Da ist Maria dabei. Ja, nee, dass wir Rampensäuer sind, ich meine, das ist ja selbstreden, sonst würden wir ja keinen Podcast machen, wo wir einfach nur von unserem Leben erzählen. Also, dass wir klar irgendwie Bock haben, dass das Leute hören und uns teilen. Man muss da schon ein ganz schön narzisstisches Arschloch sein eigentlich hier, ne? Ein bisschen so eine narzisstische Persönlichkeitsstörung sollte auf jeden Fall vorhanden sein, wenn man einen Podcast macht, aber es ist ja nicht immer nur schlimm. Übrigens habe ich neulich ein Buch gelesen über Narzissmus, das ist übrigens eine Fehlannahme, dass Narzissmus gleichzeitig heisst, dass Leute Arschlöcher sind, sondern wirklich so psychologisch, also die Definition von der narzisstischen Persönlichkeitsstörung ist eigentlich eher, dass man krass unsicher ist und so. Also dass man Unsicherheit dadurch versucht zu übertünchen oder zu überspielen, dadurch, dass man halt sehr, sehr... Aber diese Unsicherheit kommt ja auch aus Eitelkeit, weil man halt... Also du bist ja nicht unsicher, wenn dir egal, wie du wirken willst. Je wichtiger es ist, wie du wirkst, umso unsicherer wirst du ja, weil du darauf achtest. Ich wäre so gerne mal so jemand, der in sich selbst ruht. Ich glaube, alle haben diesen einen Kumpel. Ich habe also einer, der ruht einfach in sich selbst, der müsste auch scheissegal, was andere Leute von ihm denken, ich wäre so gerne dieser Mensch, der hat so wenig Probleme in seinem Frieden. Ich wäre so gerne der Mensch, aber du wärst nicht der Mensch, der du bist, wenn du der Mensch wärst. Du wärst ein uncooler Mensch, wenn du der wärst. Weil jeder Mensch ist anders. Weil jeder Mensch ist anders. Das stimmt, da hast du schon was gesagt gerade. Das war schon echt ein guter Satz. Glaubt ihr, dass so ein Kann zum Beispiel auch auf seinen kategorischen Imperativ reduziert werden will? Ja, das war bestimmt der Oberfreak, der war bestimmt super unbedingt. Voll, aber nee, wer war nochmal ein krasser Partygänger? War Hegel? Nee, ich hab gestern... Kant war auch schon... Genau, Kant war ein krasser Partygänger. Der hatte so ganz durchgeplant. Der war... ja, ich glaube auch, die würden heutzutage einen Podcast machen. Wobei Kant war, glaube ich, habe ich gestern so ein Video drüber gesehen. Und der ist wohl so ein Typ, der mega hässlich war, mega klein war, aber immer auf Partys war und sich immer mit Leuten umgeben war, immer besoffen war und hart, hat krass zu Partygänge halt war, was man sich gar nicht vorstellen kann. Das war Kant, ja, aber dessen Partys waren auch immer so ganz durchstrukturiert. Ach genau, genau. Die erste Stunde werden Anekdoten erzählt, dann wird Kanal halt analysiert und gegen Ende noch ein bisschen freie Partys. Genau, am Ende soll so eine hilarious Stimmung sein, damit alle mit einem guten Gefühl nach Hause gehen, war das, glaube ich. Eigentlich ganz geil. Klingt wie eine krass Scheissparty, ehrlich gesagt. Oder wie eine Podcast-Urbefolge. Nee, ich glaube, ich fände das total gut, weil was ich an Partys generell nicht mag, ist dieses Offene, also dass ich immer das Gefühl habe, so jetzt muss was passieren, aber es passiert nichts. Also ich mag es total gern, wenn man sagt, hey, wir treffen uns, um einen Film anzuschauen. Da bin ich sofort dabei. Und auch wenn es sich von einer Party nicht groß unterscheidet, ist es was ganz anderes, wenn du einfach nur auf eine Party gehst mit, ja, wir treffen uns halt. Das ist eine ganz andere Anspannung, das ist ein ganz anderes, was passiert jetzt, wo man ständig hinterfragt, lohnt es sich noch hier zu sein, als wenn man jetzt einfach sagt.
Du hast aber die Verantwortung auch nicht, finde ich, ob es scheisse ist, wenn es eine Party von jemand anders ist zum Beispiel.
Ja, aber ich finde, du hast schon die Verantwortung, ja gut, aber wenn du dich auf einen Film einlässt, dann weiss jeder, weswegen er da ist, jeder hat das gleiche Mindset, jeder kann in demselben abgesteckten Rahmen es genießen oder nicht genießen.
Ja, das ist ich auch.
Wohingegen bei einer Party man nicht nur den Inhalt des Rahmens immer definieren muss, sondern auch den Rahmen selbst, weil man immer sagt so, weswegen sind wir jetzt hier, was soll ich so, und das mag ich nicht, wir können uns auf die langweiligste Sache, wir können uns sagen, hey, wir treffen uns und schauen einfach zwei Stunden auf die Wand, sofort, bin ich sofort dabei, weil der Rahmen klar ist und wir sitzen alle vor der Wand und dann glaube ich, kann man was cooles draus machen aus dieser Wand anstarrenden Situation, als wenn man sagt, wir treffen uns einfach. Aber ich glaube, das ist unser Kontrollproblem, glaube ich. Exakt. Weil du kannst eine Party, das ist das uncoolste Setting, um es im Blick zu haben und Einfluss zu nehmen darauf. Du kannst die Musik nicht beeinflussen, wenn du nicht ein DJ wärst. Aber da kann man doch gemeinsam darüber ablästern dann, dann hat man auch wieder so eine gute Ebene. Ja, aber nicht, weil es dann laut ist und alle Leute besoffen sind und du mit keinem kooperieren kannst, mit niemandem kommunizieren kannst. Nicht alle Leute finden cool, wenn man darüber redet, wie scheiße die Party gerade ist. Ja, aber mir ist es lustig, dass ihr das vorgegibend erst eine Idee gehabt habt für eine Party, also wenn man auf so einer, ihr kennt das bestimmt auch, wenn man auf einer Party ist und die scheiße und dann macht man den Klassiker halt und spielt so eine Lüge halt irgendwie so. Wenn du gefragt hast, was machst du beruflich, dann sagst du ja, ich bin beim CERN, bin Mathematiker beim CERN und macht da irgendwie so und dann wenn die sagen, ja rechne doch mal was, dann findest du einfach was. Doch, mal was. Das hat mir nie jemand gesagt. Ja, wenn du sagst, du bist Mathematiker von Zern, ja, du könntest einfach nicht nachprüfen, wenn die keine Taschenrechnung dabei haben. So, dann ist mir noch nicht ein gutes Partyspiel eingefallen, dass du machen kannst, um diese Lüge, die du dann machst auf der Party, um noch geiler zu machen. Das heißt, du spielst eigentlich eine Filmrolle. Mir ist konkret eingefallen das Beispiel hier, nicht Beautiful Beautiful Minds, sondern mit Ethan Hawke, wie heißt es, Matt Damon, wo er diesen, den, den Genie spielt in dieser Schule da mit, ähm, ähm, naja, ähm, warte, Good Will Hunting. Good Will Hunting, genau. Und dann erzählst du halt immer, an der Party kommt dann eine, so ein Mädchen oder so zu dir, was machst du denn, du hast gar keinen Bock auf die Party, du willst einfach eine Lüge spielen, damit du eigentlich, über deine Ehrlichkeit, sagst du, ja, ich bin, äh, Student, ä bin Student, ja, ich bin halt so ein bisschen ... Du sagst aber nicht, dass du hochbegabt bist, ja, ich bin Hausmeister in der Uni, pass da ein bisschen auf und so. Und da zählst du diese ganze Geschichte so und guckst, ob sie draufkommt einfach so. Wenn nicht, ja geil, und wenn ja, dann ist sie eigentlich vielleicht sogar ein guter Catch und dann kannst du dir lachen und so ... Und wenn sie ja und mitmacht auch noch. Ja, wenn sie mitmacht, dann hast du ... Und irgendwie auch noch eine andere Rolle aus dem Film übernimmt und denkst so, woaa, dann hast du so, ach krass, ich bin Psychologin so, vielleicht sollst du dich mal mit mir treten, weißt du so? So grossartig wäre das. Und dann haben wir dann weitergesponnen, also irgendwie auf die Idee gekommen und dann haben wir dann angefangen, uns quasi das Spiel zu spielen, dass man dann, dann hatten wir ja richtig Spaß so, dass ich gesagt habe, okay, warte mal, ich mach jetzt noch einen neuen so und dann fängst du halt irgendwie so, ja, ich bin irgendwie, krass, ich kann mal aus der Zukunft irgendwie, aber jetzt zieh es kein weiter und so und dann halt so, keine Ahnung, Terminator und alles mögliche. Ja, war ein bisschen uncool, ich bin Hulk gewesen, ich habe eine Party, es ist nicht so gut geändert. Ja, finde ich sehr gut. Das war nur so, was mir gerade eingefallen ist. Ich glaube, da findest du, dass du jemanden richtigen gefunden hast, wenn du nicht nur schweigen kannst, sondern auch sich gegenseitig Scheisse erzählen kannst. Ja, auf jeden Fall, ja. Ist er diese Woche nicht erschienen und unser Kommentar war lame. Ja, das haben wir auch wirklich ernst gemeint. Da haben wir drüber nachgedacht. Es kam schlecht an, muss ich sagen, bei uns. Aber dann erst im Zweiten ... Das fand ich super interessant. Ihr habt ja geschrieben bei Twitter irgendwie kommentiert, lame. Da sind ja auch viele Likes, weil wir gemeinsam, glaube ich, Fans haben uns, also Leute, die das halt mögen haben. Und dann hab ich aber im ersten Moment so gedacht, hä, was ist das denn, ich geh doch da jetzt Dienstag zu denen hin, jetzt machen die da so einen Scheisskommentar. Das ist ja wie geil, das will ich ganz angekommen.
Das finde ich halt so interessant, weil ich habe den im ersten Moment komplett, also ein Wort, da steht einfach nur lame. Lame, aber lame, Punkt. Ja, man kann das auf so viele Art und Weise, es finde ich so lustig, es hat mich, ohne Scheiss, das hat ganz viel, mein ganzes Online-Überhaupt-Leseverhalten, da habe ich drüber nachgedacht. Weil wenn ich im ersten Moment was Negatives lese, wie so lame, ich hab's so gelesen, so lame, so als provozierendes so fickt euch Kommentar, dann eine halbe Stunde später guck ich da nochmal hin mit einem anderen Mindset, ich war auch da irgendwie gestresst, dann hab ich das total so verstanden wie so, ja lame, weil das einfach scheiße ist, was da auf der Welt passiert, dass wir unseren Podcast nicht, also dass das einfach nicht möglich ist. Also das finde ich wahnsinnig interessant. Aber wenn ihr was lest, also wenn ihr Nachrichten vom Kumpel lest, lest ihr das dann mit der Stimme von ihm im Kopf oder mit eurer Stimme vor? Ich stelle mir immer ein, zwei Stimme vor, wenn ich mit jemandem spreche, und das hilft einem so ein bisschen, weil man weiss, wie der andere spricht, und das hilft einem, das zu desifieren, weil das ist echt nicht einfach. Es ist eher wie Gedanken, weil du denkst ja auch nicht in deiner eigenen Stimme, es ist eher so was Telepathisches, als wenn dir jemand anderes was Telepathisches sendet und du hast dir Gedanken direkt ohne vermittelndes Medium, du hast sofort dir Gedanken im Kopf.
Das ist interessant.
Ich will gar nicht wissen, wie viele Beziehungen gescheitert sind, also wegen dieser psychologischen Sache, dass man nicht weiß, wie jemand eigentlich was meint, was er geschrieben hat auf WhatsApp oder sowas.
Ja, man liest auch, wenn man lesen will.
Ja, genau.
Wenn man Leute gerade nicht leiden kann, dann liest man die Sachen auch anders und aggressiver.
Deswegen kommt man mit Leuten, die man nicht leiden kann, auch immer in so eine komische Situation mit dem Schreiben. Das ist, glaube ich, interessant. Stimmt. Es sagt auch oft viel über Lame. Wir sind über Lame gekommen, weil ihr nicht geschienen seid. Ja, genau, da wolltest du was, einer von, du wolltest, äh, was, genau, du wolltest fragen. Ich wollte fragen, warum nicht. Ja, wir haben es halt so, äh, ich meine, ihr habt es ja auch nicht gesendet.et. Wir haben tatsächlich auch schon gepostet, bevor der Anschlag stattgefunden hat.
Wir hatten keine Zeit, leider.
Wir haben es einfach verdusselt, einen Termin zu finden, hatten keine Folge und haben tatsächlich, glaube ich, am Tag davor gepostet, wir haben leider diese Woche keine Sendung, weil wir einfach so hochsensibel sind, dass wir schon bevor das passiert ist, wir wussten, da liegt was in der Luft und es wäre besser, als keine Folge. Ruhe vom Sturm und so. Aber wir hätten die Folge nicht verschoben, deswegen.
Nee, aber ihr habt gesagt, aus Respekt von den Opfern.
Es ist nicht wahnsinnig arrogant zu behaupten, dass irgendwer... Ja, pass auf, da muss man gar nicht groß drüber reden. Ich kann es nur aus meiner Sicht, wie die letzten Tage waren, erst mal bin ich super genervt von Social Media gerade. Ja, klar. Ich will jetzt gar nicht sagen warum, aber es ist klar warum. Dann f das an irgendwie, dass die einen die Profilbilder ändern, dann fängt die anderen an zu sagen, das ist scheiße das und dann gibt es eine dritte Meta eben, wo andere Leute sich wieder aufregen, dass man sich drüber aufregt und jeder und ich sehe, ich sehe auch so hier der Kalkurve und so, weißt du, ich lese das so und denke mir so, ja gut, aber am Ende des Tages schreibst du das jetzt auch wiederum, nur damit du deine Likes und jeder der beste, gute Mensch. Ja nur um selbstpopulierung deswegen erscheint doch einfach deswegen habt eigentlich recht im nachhinein betrachtet habe ich finde ich das auch das haben auch viele leute gemacht die gesagt haben eigentlich sollte man Normalität und so einkehren lassen so wenn man so unpolitisch ist wie wir und ihr ja aber es war tatsächlich einfach das kann ich dir wirklich versichern wirklich so eine so eine richtige gemeinschaftliche Entscheidung einfach zwar so ein Gefühlsding, also es hat nichts damit zu tun gehabt, dass wir dachten, wir müssen jetzt irgendwie ein Zeichen setzen oder irgendwie uns positionieren oder sagen, jetzt machen es alle anderen nichts. Es war einfach so, wir hatten keinen Bock und wir hatten selber auf unsere Stimmen keinen Bock. So, jetzt irgendwie lustige, weil die Folge zwar auch so. Also ich kann mir einfach nicht vorstellen, dass Leute jemandem Unsensibilität vorwerfen, wenn sie was dann trotzdem veröffentlichen, weil ich finde, man kann ja Leuten auch nicht vorschreiben, wie sie zu, in Anführungszeichen, Trauern haben, weil sie müssen sich ja nicht anhören, wenn sie da gerade keinen Bock drauf haben, wenn sie gerade keinen Bock auf aufgetretene Stimmen haben, müssen sie nicht anhören, du kannst ja posten und sagen, hey, wenn ihr Bock habt, hört's an, wenn nicht, dann nicht. Ja, aber jetzt hast du halt so ein zwangsfinanziertes Projekt wie ZDF, wo einfach sehr viele, wo die meisten halt von Trauern wollen gerade, Geld reinpumpen und halt so ein gewisses Programm erwarten. Und da kommt es halt irgendwann. Also bei Linear, ich finde es noch was anderes, wenn man einen Podcast macht, den man anklicken muss von sich aus, als wenn du was guckst und guckst und irgendwann kommt das halt und du musst Aktives wegschalten, ist was anderes als Aktives anzuschalten. Und das ist, glaube ich, der Punkt, wo man sagt, okay, da muss man sensibler sein, als wenn man nur on demand zur Verfügung ist. Und dann finde ich, auch gerade weil es eine politische Sendung ist, muss man darauf anders reagieren als so ein Podcast, der auch ohne sowas funktioniert, der sowas einfach ausblenden kann, ohne irgendwie blöd zu wirken. Also abschliessend, wie war denn der Kommentar lame gemeint? Der war genau so gemeint, so ist es lame, dass ihr es nicht macht. Ja, einfach weil es für mich die falsche Reaktion drauf war, also weil ich es nicht nachvollziehen konnte und weil ich den Gedankengang dahinter nicht nachvollziehen konnte, warum jetzt, also nicht, dass ihr es nicht macht, sondern warum ihr das Gefühl habt, es nicht machen zu sollen, auf welcher Grundlage das irgendwie stattfindet. Das finde ich, ist immer so schwer nachzuweisen. Ich habe immer das Gefühl, da greifen so viele vorausgreifende Effekte, die gar nicht so erklärbar sind. Wir dürfen jetzt niemandem auf den Schlips treten. Wer sagt denn überhaupt, dass es eine Option ist, auf den Schlips zu treten? Aber es war tatsächlich, ich kann es nicht anders erklären, es war wirklich einfach nur eine komplette, spontane Bauchgefühlsentscheidung, ohne irgendwie sich zu überleben. Ihr habt ja auch das gute Recht dazu. Maria oder ich glaube irgendwie Herm oder ich glaube ich fast, irgendeiner meinte in der Gruppe so, Leute irgendwie, also es war ja auch an dem Samstag noch haben wir das entschieden, wo die Stimmung einfach, also ich glaube, das finden beide nicht. Man macht sich dadurch auch immer so wahnsinnig wichtig, dass man sagt, wir veröffentlichen es nicht aus Respekt vor den Opfern, wo ich denke, den Opfern ist es scheißegal, was irgendwie vier Medienspastis aus Deutschland machen. Das ist komplett egal. Also warum denkt ihr,et jetzt da so eine grosse Auswirkung? Das ist so, warum denkt ihr, dass ihr überhaupt in dieser Kategorie mitspielt? Es ist jetzt nicht so, als würdet ihr eine Blaskapelle durch Paris ziehen oder so. Ihr habt da nichts zu tun. Also das interessiert keine Sau. Das ist immer so, also nur um auf ein anderes Thema zu, das ist so, das ist so wie wenn zum Beispiel im Studium, im Philosophiestudium, Leute sich gemeldet haben und gesagt haben, ja da stimme ich jetzt Kant total zu bei der Sache, ich finde das auch so, wo ich mir denke, wer bist du, dass du Kant zu stimmen?
Das ist so, es ist natürlich inhaltlich und faktisch richtig, aber trotzdem, du bist nicht mal in der Nähe von irgendwas, das interessiert keine Sache, da muss ich jetzt Kant dann doch widersprechen, ich finde man sollte doch manchmal töten dürfen, so halt einfach, du bist nicht auf einer Augenhöhe. Shut the fuck up!
Das ist so dieses, du gehörst da nicht dazu.
Und dadurch, dass du reagierst und deine eigenen Handlungen in Relation zu den Ereignissen setzt,
tust du so, als hättest du damit irgendwas zu tun.
Unsere Reaktion kam auch so ein bisschen her.
Wir feiern im Moment einen Comedian, der heisst Anthony Jeselnik,
und der hat sich auf die Fahne geschrieben, dass Komödie gleich Tragödie plus Zeit
einfach gar nicht mehr stimmt, sondern er will einfach am gleichen Tag der Tragödie noch einen Gag raushauen. Und er hat das am Boston Marathon gemacht damals und hat dann gesagt, er hat an dem Tag den Gag rausgehauen bei Twitter, heute sind viele Grenzen überschritten worden, die Ziellinie sollte nicht dazu gehören. und hat halt viel Gegenwind dafür bekommen. aber es ist halt einfach ein guter Gag, da kann man sich überlegen, macht man den, muss man den an diesem Tag machen oder nicht? Und wir haben uns auch überlegt, sollte man danach einen Gag raushauen? So, der nicht, natürlich ist der Kontext wichtig und ist wichtig, wie der abzielt und das ist natürlich ein Gag, der jetzt nicht gegen die Opfer oder so zielt, sondern einfach die Stimmung gut machen soll. Wenn Scheisse passiert, dafür ist Comedy doch auch da, um die Gesellschaft davon abzuhalten, in so eine grosse Depression zu verfallen. Und warum kann man dann nicht einfach Comedy machen? Der Mickey hat doch heute auch einen rausgehauen, der so super grenzwertig war, aber eigentlich auch funny. Ich fand ihn überhaupt nicht grenzwertig. Ich fand ihn überhaupt nicht grenzwertig. Gar nicht, gar nicht grenzwertig. Ich fand der, aber ganz kurz. Hohen wir kurz alle ins Boot. Ja, der Gag war, was haben Charlie Sheen und der ISIS gemeinsam? Sie mögen keine Pariser oder sie hassen Pariser. Wo ich finde, ich finde den Gag überhaupt nicht anstössig, weil es ja von der Message her, ISIS hasst Pariser, nicht provokant ist. Ja, ich fand den ja auch gut. Der ist überhaupt nicht provokant und das finde ich immer so, da greift dann auch wieder so eine wahnsinnige Empörungsgesellschaft von wegen, ah, darf man nicht hier, bla bla, so von wegen.
Aber niemand macht sich Gedanken, niemand nimmt es auseinander noch und überlegt sich, gut, was ist da jetzt eigentlich genau gemeint, das ist immer ein Paris-Gag, das ist immer, gut, das ist ein Gag über den Terror, der gemacht wird, das ist es nicht, weil niemand macht sich immer die Mühe, um genau zu überlegen, gut, was ist da eigentlich genau drin, was steckt da eigentlich für ein Message drin und was ist das eigentlich für ein Kontext und für eine Intention. Viele Menschen mögen es halt auch einfach, sich zu empören und mögen es halt dadurch, ihre wahnsinnige Toleranz und ihr Mitgefühl mit anderen Menschen darzustellen und auch zu zeigen, öffentlich, dass sie sich über sowas aufregen. Ich finde es aber auch falsch, ihnen so wahnsinnig über den Klee zu loben und sagen, er ist so wahnsinnig mutig und provokant und haut das raus am Tag danach. Ich finde, es sollte absolut selbstverständlich sein, dass es auch Leute gibt, die dann Gags machen und andere nicht. Naja, okay. Kurzer Umweg, aber Themawechsel. Wir haben noch ein paar Gags-Fragen. Aber ich frage mich auch bei unserem Podcast, frage ich mich immer, wenn wir uns, wir verrennen uns ja auch gerne mal, also ich will jetzt nicht sagen, dass wir uns, aber wir reden ja gerade recht lange über ein Thema, was jetzt nicht irgendwie für, sagen wir mal, für uns als Typen jetzt so voll das Ding ist, wo wir uns nicht mehr so viel mehr so viel mehr so viel mehr so viel mehr so viel mehr so viel mehr so viel mehr so viel mehr so viel mehr so viel mehr so viel mehr so viel ernsthaft über was zu unterhalten. Aber habt ihr das auch manchmal dann, ich weiss immer nie genau, wenn ich dann in solchen Situationen bin mit den anderen beiden, dann überlege ich mich manchmal schon auch diesen einen Gedanken, der ist, weil wir dann so, ja, aber ob Leute jetzt in der U-Bahn gerade interessiert, ne, wenn die jetzt da fahren, jetzt nochmal... Hast du jetzt echt eine Schranke in deinem Kopf? Nee, nicht eine Schranke, nee, nee, also das um Gottes Willen, weil das musst du sofort abschalten, weil sonst verstellst du dich und dann bist du auch nicht mehr... Ja klar, aber du denkst dir offensichtlich nach, was Leute denken. Aber ich denke einfach drüber nach, im Endeffekt ist das jetzt irgendwie jetzt vielleicht auch mal gut, also jetzt wohl jetzt gar nicht, also ich kam nur gerade drauf, weil wir sehr lange über etwas Ernsthaftes geredet haben, was bei uns auch passiert. Was mir ja persönlich voll Spaß macht. Dass es Spaß macht, aber einfach, ich finde es gut, sich mit Leuten auszutauschen. Aber den Gedanken hat man doch als Podcast-Mensch, oder? Dass man denkt so, ja okay, jetzt ... Nee, ich glaube, das ist ein Thema, was auch gerade den Zeitgeist trifft. Also, auf dieser Party, wo ich dann am Wochenende Bier zapfen musste, habe ich viel mitbekommen, so Leute haben Probleme ausgeschüttet. Ach geil, hast du doch auch über die Tresen so gewischt. Ja, ja, ich habe mir vorher diesen Western-Saloon-Move gemacht, immer viel Gläser getrocknet. Und da hast du auch mal gesagt, nee, für dich keins mehr. Für dich keins mehr. Jetzt gelobt, ich hab exakt das Gegenteil gemacht. Ich hab exakt das Gegenteil gemacht. Es kam wirklich einer, so ein ultra besoffener Typ, kam hinter den Tresen, wo ich mir dachte, wow, das passiert normalerweise nicht. Da, wo ich immer was bestelle, kommt niemand hinter den Tresen. Der Kunde war überbesoffen und er wollte ein Tablett haben mit ganz viel Bier. Und ich wusste, dass das schiefgeht, weil er nicht mehr in der Lage war, ein Tablett zu tragen. Da hab ich ihm wirklich einfach zehn Biere draufgetan, mit dem Bewusstsein, dass die jetzt daneben gehen werden. Ich war also das Gegenteil von dem, der sagt, du kriegst nichts mehr. Ich hab ihm extra viel gegeben. Ist ganz viel. Aber vielleicht konnte der nur kein... Er ist gegangen und hat das ganze Tablett in diesem Club, wo wir waren, einfach über den Boden gestellt. Das heißt, du hast aber quasi gewusst, dass es passiert ist. Ich hab gewusst, dass es passiert ist. Und du standst dann da, hast weiter in deinen Dresel so abgewischt und lacht. Und lacht. Und schmunzelt zugeguckt. So ein Arschloch bin ich. Hast du dann so ganz cool gesagt, dass die Musik aus warst und gesagt, ja, ich hab's euch doch gesagt, Leute. Hattest du auch eine Shotgun unterm Tresen, so dass wenn du Schläger auflegt und so tsch tsch tsch und alle sind ruhig? Ich hab mir aber gerade überlegt, du hast ja gesagt, es würde schief gehen, weil man hat ja schon gesehen, dass er besoffen, der kann ja nicht mal so ein leeres Tablett tragen. Da habe ich mir gedacht, vielleicht kann der ja nur Tabletts richtig tragen, wenn da Gewicht drauf ist. Das kann sein. Das kann sein. Das erdet so, dass er dann... Ja, das stimmt. Oft sind ja schwere Dinge einfacher zu tragen als leichte Dinge. Stimmt. Das waren so wie Probleme. Der war hart besoffen wirklich und ist dann wirklich dagegen mit dem ganzen Körper so gegen die Wand gelaufen. Wobei man auch dachte, am Anfang, also eigentlich sagt man nicht, besoffene Menschen verletzen sich nicht. Habe ich mal gedacht, gut, legen wir ihm sehr viel Bier darauf und er hat auch ein paar davon noch getrunken. Wir testen diese Hypothese jetzt mal. Hier hast du vier Messer und eine brennende Fackel. Er hat sich verletzt, weil er gegen die Wand gelaufen ist. Da dachte ich mir, okay, Mythbusters. Du erzählst die Story jetzt vielleicht nicht komplett und lässt Dinge weg, aber ich möchte jetzt schon mal sagen, du bist der schlechteste Buggy bei der Welt. Also einfach das mal als Fazit. Oder der Beste halt. Das ist so schwierig, Bier zu zapfen. Der Beste und der Schlechteste liegen ja oft auch sehr nah beieinander. Ja, wie würdest du das? Ich finde es so lustig, wie ich mal angucke. Wenn du meinst, einen bedeutungsschwangeren Satz gesagt zu haben, dann kriegst du immer diese komische Stimme, diese weiche Stimme und guckst den Gästen immer so tief in die Augen, wo ich mir denke, bitte reagier da jetzt drauf, Gast, aber es wird einfach ein creepy Moment.
Ich versuche ihn zu beeindrucken, ich versuche da nichts zu einigen. Mir fällt gerade ein, ich bin ja vorhin hergefahren mit dem Taxi vom Bahnhof, da war original gerade die Ansage von im Radio, mit dem Taxifahrer kam ins Radio, dass das Spiel heute abgedingst. Was war da eigentlich los? Keine Ahnung, wahrscheinlich war da einfach nur eine normale, in Anführungsstrichen, normale Bombe-Drohung, die wir jetzt natürlich mega... Das ist nichts Besonderes sein. Jil, aber jedenfalls fahr ich, ist geil, kommt ja erst noch nach. Sitze ich so da und dann fängt der Taxifahrer an, war so ein, ich glaube, er war für ein Ausländer, ich glaube eher Türke oder sowas, keine Ahnung, weiß ich ja nicht genau. Weiß ich ja nicht genau, aber darum geht es eigentlich, er hat einfach krasse Ansichten gehabt so, und er hat einfach angefangen, ungefragt darüber zu reden, und kennt ihr das, das ist immer so super unangenehm, weil ich hatte erstens die Energie nicht und zweitens einfach gar nicht den Bock, mit dem jetzt zu diskutieren. Und es ist wie wenn du irgendwie einen Nazi mitbekommst und du tust einfach nix, weil du denkst, ach ey, gar keine Energie. Und er hat irgendwas Dummes gesagt, von wie irgendwie, ja, ja, ja, Frankfurt, selbe Schuld, so fängt, so fing der Satz an. Und ich sag, okay, war ich schon raus, so ne? Und dann sitz ich da, war so... Aus dem fahrenden Auto rausgesprungen. Ja, aber das Geile war jetzt, das kann man sich nicht ausdenken,
ich fahr dann so und war eh schon echt so ein bisschen nervös auch so, hierher zu kommen, weil ich nicht wusste, was erratet mich hier und so, bin ich jetzt da, geh ich da voll unter, bin voll unlustig, meine ganze Reputation ist für den Arsch, so für immer, die werden voll gemein zu mir sein und so, fahr dann da hin und trink mal ein Gapel, gefühlt mich eh so ein bisschen scheiße und er erzählt diesen Quatsch und was kommt im Radio, everybody hurts. Eine schöne Schwarz-Weiss-Sequenz.
Ich wollte es noch aufnehmen, weil ich mir dachte, das glaubt mir keiner. Es hat auch geregnet, es hat geregnet auch noch in Köln und ich war da und hör mir diesen Depp da an und trink meinen Dosen-Gaffel-Kölsch, was übel scheisse schmeckt, da habe ich mir so, okay, jetzt wird auch bestimmtes Interview oder hier Interview, also der Podcast scheisse und okay, das ist ein Zeichen so, aber es war ja dann okay. Aber du hast ja, also wenn man sich deinen Lebenslauf anschaut, da sind ja viele Dinge passiert und viele Höhen und Tiefen irgendwie, du hattest mal eine eigene Sendung, die wurde dann abgesetzt, du hast mal eine Webshow moderiert, da wurde es dann rausgeschmissen. Also viele Tiefen, vor allem viele stimmt aber auch nicht. Du hast ja ein verrücktes Leben, hattest du irgendwann mal so Tiefpunkte, wo du dachtest, okay, jetzt geht gar nichts mehr? Nee, ich glaube, man muss das jetzt, bei dir weiss man ja nie, ob du das jetzt wirklich so halb ironisch meinst oder nicht, aber das Problem habe ich in meinem Leben auch oft, aber ich beantworte es einfach mal ernsthaft. Also erstens bin ich ja, habe ich diese eine Sendung gemacht mit Nils, die ist ja wirklich abgesetzt worden, das war auch Kacke, da bin ich auch nach wie vor der Meinung, dass da ZDF Neo einfach dumm war, weil das eigentlich eine coole Sendung war, ein gutes Potenzial hatte.
Muss man das eigentlich intervenieren, wenn man arbeitet quasi?
Ja, aber da waren irgendwelche, keine Ahnung, das war einfach komisch, auch die ganze Argumentation war komisch.
Und die andere Sendung bin ich ja nicht rausgeworfen worden übrigens, sondern einfach, da habe ich aufgehört, weil ich dann keine Lust mehr hatte, ehrlich gesagt, auch jetzt gerade momentan nicht mehr so Bock habe, vor der Kamera zu sein, weil ich da einfach daraus gelernt habe, also ich bin halt so ein Typ, ich glaube, also ich kriege halt, wie gesagt, früher Klassenklauen gewesen, ich kann auch, glaube ich, manchmal ganz lustig sein und auch, ich kann auch ganz okay moderieren und so und das Problem bei mir war immer, ich habe immer Sachen bekommen oder Angebote bekommen und so, wo man sich halt, wo Leute einen so in eine Schublade stecken wollen, das heißt, die sehen irgendwie die eine Sendung und sagen, da kommen so ein Manager an und sagen so, ah, du doch der Typ, du bist ein crazy irgendwie, so lustig und so, smart auch ein bisschen, graue Haare, crazy und dann schicken die mir, und das Ding ist ja mein Vorteil wahrscheinlich oder eigentlich mein Nachteil, wenn es darum geht, irgendwie famed zu werden als Moderator oder so immer, dass ich ja auch Autor bin und mir die Sachen dann immer vorher schicken lasse und mir das selber angucke, was das so ist und ob das lustig ist. Und ich es einfach in 99 Prozent der Fälle einfach scheisse finde und immer denke, wenn ich da mitmache, dann würde ich mich super unglücklich fühlen und würde wahrscheinlich die ganze Zeit nur voll die Diva am Set sein, nicht weil ich ein Arsch bin, sondern weil ich denke, man könnte es besser machen, bla bla und du willst ja immer bei Drehs musst du eigentlich einfach nur funktionieren, weil der Redakteur und alle Leute haben einfach keinen Bock auf deinen Gelaber, die wollen einfach so, mach das jetzt so stand drin, jetzt hör auf mit deinem, wie du es besser machen kannst, bla bla bla. So, und das ist der Grund, warum ich gerade nicht mehr so vor der Kamera arbeiten möchte, weil mich das irgendwann ... Ich habe einfach gemerkt, je älter man wird, desto weiser wird man ja, einfach gemerkt, ich bin einfach vom Typ her nicht der Typ, der sich gerne, weil es eigentlich voll der Widerspruch ist, aber der sich so anbiedert. Obwohl ich super gerne im Mittelpunkt stehe, gerne auch meinen Lob abbekomme und irgendwie Likes im Internet und irgendwie auch so irgendwie dann irgendwie so halb Fame bekomme, ist ja normal.
Aber ich kann nicht dieses so, mich so verkaufen, zu Leuten hingehen und sagen so, ey, ich habe das und das gemacht, ich mache das und das, ich moderiere jetzt die Sendung hier, geil ab. Übrigens ein neues Album, die ganze Magazine gewesen. Okay, die liest das Magazin, ja. Das kann ich irgendwie nicht und ja, es war jetzt sehr weit ausgeholt, aber ich glaube, das erklärt, ich muss so weit aus, um zu erklären, warum ich irgendwie da bin, wo ich halt bin und jetzt lieber gerade hinter der Kamera arbeite und Sachen schreibe und down the line, wie man so schön sagt, gerne mal irgendwann was Eigenes schreiben würde. Also ein Format, wo ich eben diese Probleme dann halt nicht habe, wo ich dann machen kann, was ich möchte, weil ich das selber sozusagen erfunden oder geschrieben habe. Ist also quasi eine Bewerbung an Tele 5 jetzt, sind die eigene Donny O'Sullivan-Shows. Welches Montagsmaler wieder aufbeleben lassen.
Allein zu machen.
Der Klügere kippt nach, ist abgesetzt worden, nachdem nichts da war. Ja, leider. Genau, einen Tag später. What? Gibt es noch neue Folgen jetzt? Und bevor Aurel da war, und vor allem von mir Aurel Merz, kurz bevor er auftreten sollte, wurde die Sendung abgesetzt. Einfach so kurz ab. So uncool. Zwanzig Minuten vorher, er hat schon Luft geholt, so abgesetzt. Wie interessant die Sichten sind, das ist deine Sicht, weil es dein Kumpel ist und bei mir ist halt so, also abgesetzt bevor er auftritt, bei mir ist halt Nils abgesetzt, nachdem er da war. Ja, genau. Boah, habe ich jetzt voll lang Quatsch erzählt über meine ganze Moderationsansicht und so? Ja, das ist das lang. Nein, wir wollen auch mal so ein paar emotionale Punkte haben. Nein, nur keine Emotionen, da war eben ein massiver Schnitt, Leute. Das war jetzt die Erklärung. Kein Wunderbar um die letzten zehn Minuten nur Musik lief, warum wir Donnys neues Album Monday is the new Sunday hier gerade noch mal in voller Länge gehört haben. Aber du machst ja wahnsinnig viele Dinge, du schreibst, du machst irgendwie so Werbekram und so, Musik gemacht, Moderation und so. Ist es eine Unentschlossenheit oder bist du einfach so ein Pfau und brauchst viele Farben in deinem Leben? Es ist absolute Unentschlossenheit, leider. Mega, mega schlimm.
Ohne Entschlossenheit?
Ich sag immer, ich hab diese eine Metapher, die ich immer sag, die irgendwie voll scheiße eigentlich ist.
Jeder Mensch ist anders.
Nee, jeder Mensch ist anders.
Wie eine Schafel-Pralin.
Erstens, ich fahr immer ganz viele Züge, aber nie einen bis zum Endbahnhof, so. Irgendwie, keiner ist so schlimm.
Moment, Moment, Moment, Moment, Moment.
Oh, das ist viel Züge.
Ah, Metapher-Alarm.
Nee, ganz klar Unentschlossenheit, ja, leider. Warte mal, wir finden bestimmt eine bessere Metapher für dich. Wir sind sowas wie die Metapher Kings im Podcast. B-b-b-b-b-b-b-b-b-b-b-b-b-b-b-b-b-b-b-b-b-b-. Das war mir dann, da habe ich echt gedacht, fuck, die sind so voll die hochintelligenten, hochbegabten, ich kann das gar nicht. Ich habe da mal so ein Spiel gemacht mit diesem, was ich ehrlich gesagt auch super scheisse fand, weil es voll unlustig war. Aber ich hab's nicht verstanden. Ihr habt so ein komisches Metapher-Spiel gespielt, wo man irgendwie, oder nicht Metapher, sondern so ein Assoziationsspiel. Ah ja, ein Kompromissspiel, glaube ich, oder? Ich hab's nicht ganz gecheckt. Einer sagt irgendwie ein Wort und dann musst du das nächste Wort nehmen. Ah, bis man sich damit trifft. Bis man sich dann trifft. Das hat nicht funktioniert. Das fand ich super scheisse. Das war auch scheiße. Aber cool, danke fürs Feedback. Da freut man sich ja doch drüber. Aber da dachte ich halt echt, krass, das sind so voll die Rainmans, die irgendwie so mega Comedy quasi am Mathebrett quasi formulieren. Ich denke mir auch direkt am Schreibtisch aus, mit einer Formel. Die Matheformel. Aber ist es nur beruflich bei dir so, dass du unentschlossen bist oder auch sonst so? Auch sonst so generell, jall, ja. Du bist quasi wie ein Knutzer. Ich bin der schlimmste Entscheidungstreffer der Welt, so. Ganz schlimm, ja. Ich kann nie in den Urlaub fahren, auch deswegen. Weil ich immer denke, ja, wenn ich jetzt irgendwie, wenn ich anfange, Urlaub zu buchen, dann klassisch so, hier Urlaub eingegeben bei Google halt, ne. So das erste, was da kommt, ja, ja, ab in den Urlaub, klingt geil, passt schon, Ballack, ja. Aber du verfällst dann nicht in Passivität, sondern du machst dann trotzdem noch was. Ja. Weil es oft so, wenn ich mich nicht entscheiden kann, mache ich gar nichts. Ja, wenn es um solche Sachen wie Urlaub und so geht, tatsächlich leider schon. Ich gehe dann einfach nicht in Urlaub und so. Was ist denn mit Supermarkt? Du hast den Auftrag, Chips zu kaufen. Ja, aber der Klassiker, dann komme ich da an mit zehn anderen Sachen und die Chips vergesse ich dann meistens. Stehst du dann sehr lange vor den Chips trotzdem wie ich? Ja, voll. Du kannst dich nicht entscheiden. Mir ist neulich aufgefallen, ich mein, wahrscheinlich gibt's jedem so, man geht ja immer, man hat ja einen so einen Stammsupermarkt, ne, so. Da geht man da hin und es gibt diesen, ich nenne ihn jetzt immer den Standardeinkauf, den man macht ohne gross zu überlegen, das was du halt brauchst, so irgendwie die gleichen Schinken, die du immer holst, den Toast, Nutella sind es bei mir halt. Und manchmal denke ich mir so, hä, wieso mache ich das eigentlich, kann ich nicht mal selber ausbrechen und so mal, da kennst du, weil anders, kennt ihr das, was kam dann, was kam da raus am Ende?
Kennt ihr das nicht, wenn ihr bei Freunden seid zum Beispiel, zum Brunchen oder so, hey, man trifft sich ganz kurz, und dann haben die so einen Schinken, den du nie kaufen würdest, aber dann probierst du den, schmeckt dir voll gut, und dann, aber erwischst du dich wieder dabei, wenn du wieder selber, und dann kaufst du wieder den, den du kennst, so, na, der war zwar ganz geil bei dem Brunch, aber keine Ahnung. Und mittlerweile versuche ich sowas zu kaufen. Aber was ist denn der Ausbruch-Einkauf von Donny O'Sullivan, dem grossen Smoothie-Problem? Was kauft der sich, wenn er nicht das normale kauft? Was war dieser Ausbruch-Einkauf von dir mal? Kommt dann die Wassermelone direkt, kommt das krasse Smoothie mit den Früchten, die du noch kennst? Ja, tatsächlich Smoothie wollte ich gerade sagen, tatsächlich. Donny aus Gettels. Da kommt halt so Smoothie-Geschichten und so. Neulich habe ich eine Kokosnuss gekauft, wo ich einfach gar nicht wusste, wie die öffnet. Wer hat die Kokosnuss gekauft? Der neue Hit von Donny Osalvin. Der grosse. Wow. Und eine Ananas habe ich neulich gekauft. Ich kaufe mir auch mal sowas und dann liest du die Woche lang in meiner Wohnung rum und fängt an, ganz interessant zu riechen.
Aber das ist ja der Klassiker, so dass ich, ich weiss gar nicht, wie viele Bananen ich meinem Leben schon gekauft habe, wo ich mir einfach denke, so ich sitze da, ich stehe da im Supermarkt, nur Chips, Cola und alles so und sie diese Banane und sie guckt mich an und ich so, ja, okay, komm, ich kauf dich jetzt halt, weil dann will ich wenigstens nicht ganz so scheiße aussehen und die gammelt eh weg dann. Aber kenn die diese ganz, ganz kleinen Orangen, diese Kumquats, diese ganz winzigen Dinger, wo ich auch mal einfach so eine Hand von gekauft habe und man könnte das wirklich in so einem Comic darstellen, ich bring sie nach Hause, leg sie auf den Tisch, dann sieht man so eine Uhr, eine Woche vergeht, nichts passiert und ich nehme sie so wie sie sind und werfe sie in Müll. Aber vielleicht solltest du auch da noch so Daumen hoch machen und so auf so einem Clipboard, so einen Haken. Die kaufe ich beim nächsten Mal wieder. Genau, die haben gut gegangen. Empfehlung, die kaufe ich beim nächsten Mal wieder. Haben sich lange gehalten. Aber dann bist du auch unzufrieden, wenn die sich länger halten, sozusagen. Ja, genau. Hä, wieso gammelt das denn jetzt nicht? Das ist genau wie Tupperdosen. Man ist zur Hälfte, tut die Hälfte die Tupperdose, eine Woche vergeht und man wirft's weg. Einfach jedes Mal. Tupperdosen, falls sie etwas noch eine Woche aufheben wollen, bevor sie es wegschmeissen. Das ist gute Werbung auf jeden Fall. Ja, natürlich isst man es nicht mehr. Ich bin neulich nicht ausgeworfen, habe einen Standorteinkauf gemacht, aber nur so ein paar Sachen, die ich brauche. Und das war halt genau am 11.11. in Köln, wo halt wirklich so ganz viele Jugendliche rauskommen. Und dann waren wirklich die 16-Jährigen, die zum ersten Mal ein Bier kaufen können, dann haben die 18 zum ersten Mal Wodka kaufen können. Und die haben so die krassesten Einkäufe getätigt, vor mir an der Kasse haben sich noch durchgeschmuggelt. Und dann kam ich mit meinen pinken Smoothies, die irgendwie auch pink und rot waren, und dann noch irgendwie ein Wasser und irgendwie so einen Salat oder so. Und das wirklich so uncool, da dachte ich mir auch, ich muss mir jetzt irgendwie Zigaretten noch kaufen, damit ich so für mich sind. Ich muss mir einfach nur Kondome und die XXL Gleitgehe packen. Sorry, ich muss jetzt irgendwas machen. Ich muss jetzt irgendwas machen, damit ich nicht uncool wirkt. Vor mir waren so Kids, die irgendwie so 16 waren und zum ersten Mal irgendwie Wodka kaufen und es so mega cool gefühlt haben. Und dann war ich immer in meinen Pink Smoothies, das war der uncoolste Einkauf, weil irgendwie Fisherman's Friends Cherry oder nachher, das war wirklich der uncoolste Einkauf überhaupt und Küchenpapier. Offiziell ausgebrochen. Ich dachte mir so, Scheiße. Stefan, Natsle, Breakout. Ich dachte mir echt, so uncool. Und dann habe ich echt noch Zigaretten gekauft. Aber rauchst du? Nein, noch nie geraucht. Auch einfach zu Hause hingestellt, eine Woche weg. Und versteckt, weißt du dann ... Falls die Eltern mal kommen, versteckt sie. Ich stell mir gerade vor, wie du so die Zigaretten aufs Laufband legst und so dich nach hinten umdrehst zu diesen anderen Jugendlichen, die mit ihren Alkopops da stehen. Und dann nimmst du so diese, schüttelst sie so, ratet so. Genau, nimmst diese pinke Sache und schmeißt sie einfach so weg, als ob ich das echt kaufen wollte. Und dann machst du dir aber eine Zigarette an, auch an der Kasse. Sie dürfen nicht rauchen, sorry, sorry. Aber das finde ich einen sehr schönen Move, du kaufst dir etwas, nur um es zu verstecken und nie zu benutzen. Es ist ein Geheimnis, du versteckst es aber vor wem. Das finde ich psychoanalytisch sehr interessant. Am 11.11. war ich im ICE tatsächlich und ich meine, wir kennen das. ICE steht für... Kommt immer spät. Ich... Chille einsam. Ich chille einsam. Okay. Und man steht dann irgendwann, und wir haben bestimmt eine Stunde, zwei Stunden Verschwellung gehabt, und es standen ewig rum. Das Geile war, dass die Hälfte der Zuggäste einfach verkleidet waren. Und es gibt nichts Schöneres als wütende Leute in allem an den Träumen. Vor allem auch morgens, wenn die Zeit noch nicht da ist, um verkleidet zu sein, aber Leute zu ihren Treffpunkten kommen, wo es dann legitimes verkleidet zu sein. Es gibt aber am 11.11. legitime Treffpunkte, wo man akzeptiert, dass sie verkleidet sind, aber dann, wenn der Weg dahin, auch zur Schule, wo Leute einzeln sind und in der Minderheit sind verkleidet und auch nur müde sind und dann haben die diesen ernsten Blick und sitzen dann so ernst in diesem Dino-Kostüm in der U-Bahn und fahren dann so und die U-Bahn wackelt und daneben ist die Oma, die irgendwie dann noch wieder die Tasche stürzt und dann sind die sauer und dann ist die Bahn zu spät und dann sitzen dann die Cowboys und Barbies und Feen einfach so wütend und schlaftrunk in der U-Bahn. Sie haben ihr Froschkostüm, man haben aber noch einen Anorak drüber, dass man das Kostüm nicht sieht, und du siehst nur einen mürrischen Typen mit Froschschminke im Gesicht, aber man sieht nichts von dem Kostüm, einfach nur so ein Typ, der böse ist und begann aus dem Racken. Ich muss nach Köln ziehen, ey, das ist so ein Köln. Aber das ist einfach so, ich stelle mir vor, der Tag dieses Schaffners, wo einfach ständig irgendeine wutentbrannte Giraffe durch den Gang stapft und einfach mit so Herzchen auf den Wangen so, ja wann geht's denn jetzt ehrlich weiter, wir warten hier schon eine Stunde. Aber was ich tatsächlich gesehen habe, was sehr interessant war, so ganz anamorphe Kostüme, die nichts darstellen sollten, sondern nur so ein weisser Anzug, wo dann so Love, irgendwie Sex drauf stand und so Herzchen und so, das aber nichts darstellen sollte, sondern so komisch irgendwie. Ja, in Köln ist das so, da haben Leute einfach dann so gestreifte T-Shirts an, die einfach rot-weiss gestreift sind und das ist dann so deren Angebot als Kostüm. Und wenn ihr dann kauft, dann macht es doch wenigstens richtig, also wenn ihr schon euch verkleidet und diese Lächerlichkeit darstellt, dann doch bitte richtig. Einfach nur so ein gestreiftes T-Shirt, okay. Aber geht's da nicht darum, einfach so ... Im Grunde genommen, mir wurde das immer so erklärt, in Köln geht's eigentlich nur darum, wenn man Single ist, bei Fasching oder hier Karneval einfach flachgelegt zu werden. Also, dass alle besoffen sind und dann wird rumgeknutscht, mega einfach und deswegen sind wahrscheinlich genau die Leute, die so, ja, scheiss drauf, ich war mal jetzt irgendwie so, werf ich um, aber ich bin geil halt so, ne? Ja klar, das ist natürlich blöd, Stefan.
Ich bin mit Stormtrooper-Kostüm, keine Chance.
Ich wollte gar nichts sagen, da kommst du ja gar nicht ran halt, ne?
Nee, kommst du nicht ran, kannst nicht pinkeln, darfst also nichts trinken und kotzt dir aber,
du konntest dir nicht in deinen Helm und deine eigene Rüstung.
Ich fand ja das beste Kostüm damals, als ich gesehen habe, auch so ein Internetbild halt, ne,
so aus den Annalen des Internets, dieses von so zwei Typen auf einer WG-Party, die so ein schwarz-weiss gestriftenes Hemd haben mit so einer Baskenmütze und so, also offensichtlich so alle französischen Klischees, Gitan, aber dann geschminkt im Gesicht halt wie die Band Kiss und dann halt so French Kiss, das fand ich ganz gut. So zusammen, so in der Kombo, das fand ich gut. Auch so ein Geh, wo man nachdenken muss, das fand ich toll. Ja, das fand ich gut. Ja, das fand ich gut. Ja, das fand ich gut.
Ja, das fand ich gut.
Ja, das fand ich gut. Ja, das fand ich gut. Ja, das, aber halt noch ein Anoraktrück. Ja, aber dann auch so Gore-Tex und so, alles so atmungsaktiv. Aber ich stelle mir das auch in den Filmen so vor, zum Beispiel Voldemort, der hat ja echt nur so eine ganz dünne Robe an, dann will er Hogwarts angreifen, zieht sich aber noch mal schön anoraktrück an, so ein ganz lastiger, und mit so einem Tartonka-Rucksack noch um und greift da mit Hogwarts an, so ein mega uncooles Kostüm. Weil ich mein, so sehen Leute, so mit Leuten aussehen, so ein Stirnband einfach, weil er einfach geil ist. Ja, oder wenn's realistisch wäre. Ja, so einen grossen Deuter-Rucksack oder so einen uncoolen Wander-Rucksack. Deuter ist gut. Oder Faudel. Gab's da für Faudel, diese Tätigkeit. So einen Völkel-Rucksack, wo man unterwegs ist. Und so eine Jack-Wolkskin-Jacke, weil die einfach ... Das ist doch wirklich so. So eine Käppchen mit so Ohren dran. So eine hunderttreue-pumpe Schellmütze. Die Bösewichte sind einfach auch nie wirklich pragmatisch. Die tragen dann nicht irgendwie die Payback-bezahlten Just-Sports-Rucksäcke, sondern die tragen dann eigentlich gar keinen Rucksack. Ich hab ja eh, Das erinnert mich gerade an was. Ich liebe ja so Vorstellungen, auch zum Beispiel bei Braveheart, da gibt es ja diese eine, es gibt ja mehrere grosse Reden von Mel Gibson auf dem Pferd, aber diese eine ganz grosse, wo sie kurz davor ihren Arsch zeigen und so, er hat doch da unglaubliche Menschenmenge, links und rechts geht's kilometerweit hinter einem Amassen von Leuten, er ist an diesem kleinen Punkt zehn Meter und kreist da mit seinem Pferd hin und her und macht seine grosse Rede. Ich will's unbedingt mal nachdrehen, aber alles muss auch mit den gleichen Kameras, damit der Gag funktioniert. Dass ganz rechts einer sagt. Lauter, können Sie ein bisschen lauter sprechen, ich versteh kein Wort. Was, woher kämpfen wir, woher kämpfen wir, woher sollen wir sterben? Oder das eine Arschloch, was hinten immer ruft, Lauter bitte, bisschen deutlicher. Oder der zu spät kommt, worum geht es mit dem, genau, siehst du gar nicht, aber der Gagsalter gibt es ja öfter, der hat mega viele gute Sachen, aber der muss dann halt auch wirklich mit diesen fetten Kameras, es muss alles, der Gips muss wieder mitmachen, im Hintergrund irgendwie dazukommen, es muss alles so, dass es sich einordnen. Und dann sind zwei Arschloch, die irgendwie, ja, Claudia hat gestern übrigens, wenn ihr ermahnt werden von ihm. er hält seine Sprache, er macht seine Bauchtasche auf, zieht sein Schwert raus und stürmt zum Angriff. Du bist ein cooler Typ. Lass uns mal ganz kurz rum. Das ist so, WG-Paar, die behindert um drei Uhr, irgendwie so völlig besoffen. Du bist ein cooler Typ. Von dir habe ich alles gelernt. Von dir habe ich alle Alben. Ich bewundere dich wirklich. Aber lass uns mal ganz kurz um ein Cooles reden. Und zwar, ich finde Leute extrem uncool, die auf jedwege Entweder-Oder-Frage beides sagen. Das ist mega uncool. Und da möchte ich jetzt auch mal ganz kurz ein Machtwort sprechen. Sagt nie auf Entweder-Oder-Fragen beides. Und vor allem reagiert nicht cool auf beides. Das ist schlechtmöglichste. Ist das bei dir das Gleiche mit Jein? Also Jein sagen geht auch nicht? Jein geht auf gar keinen Fall, das habe ich in irgendeinem Konix mal gesehen, so was, irgendein Song, da haben die über Frauen geredet und dann so, bist du eher so ein Ärscher oder Titten-Typ? Und er so, beides. Und dann so, nein, nein, das ist einfach die unkreativste Dutzendung auf die Frage. Alle haben im Kino gelacht, ich hatte einen Kopfhörer geschüttelt, er wirkt. Alle haben im Kino gelacht, das wär ja auch geil, wer so ein Film wäre, und du bist der einzige, der aufsteht. Nein! Halt, stopp! Moment, das ist kein guter Gag. Halt mal kurz den Leimann an. Und die Leimann dauert ewig, bis die den überhaupt wahrnehmen, die Leute. Das heißt, du stehst die ganze Zeit da, bis ... Nee, ich warte jetzt hier. Könnt ihr, hallo, runterkommen? Ja, ich bin hier, ja, ja. Und dann selbst vergessen, dass es rumsteig ging. Irgendwann kommt so ein Typ rein und, was ist denn hier los, was machst du denn da, mach mal aus. Hab ich dir schon mal erzählt mit diesem Bildfehler im Kino, dass wir mal im Kino waren und dann ging der Film los und das Bild war verschoben. Also die obere Hälfte des Bildes war unten. Das war 3D, du musst die Brille aufziehen. Ah, nicht schlecht. Hey, klassischer Gästliste Geisterbahngeg. Also dann Donnie, kriegst ein D. Also die untere Hälfte war oben und die obere Hälfte war unten und in der Mitte war so ein grauer Strich einfach durch. Und dann schaut man diesen Film an, zwei Minuten, drei Minuten und dann überlegt man schon so, was passiert jetzt? Also soll man sich irgendwo melden? Bis tatsächlich irgendwann nach fünf Minuten einer aus der ersten Reihe Filmstrich! Und dann dauert es 20 Sekunden und dann zack, wird geändert und passt wieder. Aber ich finde es so gut, dass er das... Ja, der genau das richtige Wort kannte. Fachvokabular gibt. Filmstrich! Er sollte sagen, Filmfehler, nicht passiert, die Leinwand ist gewohnt. Der obere ist unten und...hm Filmstrich, ja richtig, richtiger Wort. Der Film war da bestimmt auch überall so Gaffer kleben und so, da war so ein richtiger. Und vor allem er hat halt fünf Minuten gewartet, er dachte sich so, weiss es jemand, weiss es jemand, okay, Filmstrich, einfach so mega und Patsch. Aber dafür studiert man Filmmissenschaften, dass man der eine Arsch sein kann, der das richtige großen Moment gehabt in seinem Leben? Ich stell dir mal vor, dass da oben jemand in diesem Vorführraum einfach auch schläft. Und wenn er einfach so ein paar Wörter hat, wo er dann aufstreckt, irgendwie aus seinem Schlaf. Und Filmstrich gehört ja tief dazu. Oh, hast du Walter Mitty gesehen, den Ben Stiller-Film? Nee. Walter Mitty. Und in diesem Film geht es darum, um ganz kurz zu fragen, es soll ein neues Cover für das Time Magazine geben. Und Foto, das das Cover werden soll, geht verloren und Ben Stiller zieht in die Welt hinaus und will dieses Bild finden.
Und man fragt sich natürlich den ganzen Film über, a findet er das Bild und was ist dieses Bild, warum ist es so wichtig, dass er es findet. Und dann am Ende, Spoiler, Spoiler, Spoiler, man weiss nicht, sieht man das Bild am Ende oder nicht und du siehst dann so, er läuft dann so über die Strasse und sieht an einem Kiosk das Time Magazine und dann fährt die Kamera auf dieses Bild und du könntest es sehen und in dem Moment wird die gesamte Leinwand schwarz. Alles ist schwarz. Und alle denken sich, okay, geil und es bleibt schwarz und schwarz, alles schwarz und tatsächlich ohne Witz ist der Projekt da ausgefallen. Wir hatten auch die Musik gehört. Also es war gar nicht abgleich mit dem Film zu dürfen. Musik ist weitergegangen, der Projekt ist ausgefallen, auch die Credits kamen am Ende, so diese Musik. Und dann so, was ist denn jetzt los? Einfach, er ist wirklich in dem Moment, in dem der spannendste Teil des Films kommen würde. Und dann dachten so, ah ja, okay. Ja, aber das kann ja kein Zufall sein, aber bestimmt. Aber wo ich mir auch dachte so, und dann kam irgendwann so einer rein, so, ja, ja, bleiben Sie kurz sitzen, wir spulen kurz zurück. Und es nochmal, dann haben wir das Ending gesehen. Das fand ich auch cool, dass es dramaturgisch Sinn ergibt.
Ist ja geil.
Ja, vielleicht müssen das alle weltweit von dem Verleih alle so hier Filmmacher machen, sozusagen. Wie heißen die hier? Projektorbediener? Projektionisten, ja, aber das Medium Film verlassen an der Stelle, zu sagen, man spielt mit dem Medium. The Medium is the message. Ach, apropos Film verlassen, ich war ja letzte Woche in diesem Macbeth drin, ne?
So, und so Klassiker, nix zu tun gehabt am Freitagabend, einfach auch mal alleine ins Kino, ne, das kann man ja mal machen. Das freie ich mir auch immer, wann das einsetzt, dass man das machen kann. Das ist eigentlich geil, du musst einfach nur Selbstbewusstsein und das machen. Bewusstsein muss es einsetzen, dass man das macht. Man muss so einsam sein. Ja, nee, das ist super. Und da waren auch nur Pärchen und so, es war auch komisch, irgendwie ein bisschen unangenehm, aber wenn du das ausstrahlst, dass alles klar ist, dass du alleine da bist, so mit mega viel Chips und so, dann ist es okay. Aber du hast trotzdem den Pärchen-Knutsch-Sessel genommen, damit du deine Chips nehmen kannst. Oh, natürlich, bist trotzdem mit dem Tandem gekommen, seltsamerweise. Ich habe halt auch so dumme Gags gemacht in der Schlange, ich versuche dann immer meine eigene Unsicherheit, da irgendwie das Eis zu brechen, was gar nicht da ist, irgendwie so. Nur zwischen Pärchen beim Schütteln, naja, ich hole mir Aure, kommt gleich nach. Meine Freundin ist gerade Karte da. So einen Frauenmantel mitgenommen. Okay, schau, den Daumen hoch, weglaufen, stolpern. Du hast auch so eine Handtasche dabei, sie müsste gleich kommen, jeden Moment. Aber da kommt tatsächlich dann immer dieser bemitleidenswerte Blick des Kassiers. Nur eine Karte? Ja. Ja. Nur eine Karte. Das ist genauso wie mit den Stäbchen, wenn die dann irgendwie immer zwei reinlegen, wenn ich Sushi bestelle. Das machen wir ja auch auch! Ich bin so fett, dass ich irgendwie Leute zu Besuch hab. Das ist nicht schlecht für einen Stand-Up. Ja, aber das ist ein Classic-Stand-Up. Das ist ein Nine-Gag-Gag. Ja, ja, genau. Nine-Gag-Gag. Also nichts gegen dich ist okay. Hey, aber das ist ein Classic-Gag. Ich war ja einer der ganz frühen Nine-Gag-Menschen, wo ich immer noch, eigentlich schon längst nicht mehr drüber rede, aber ich hab eine Zeit, wo ich so richtig viel Energie hatte und Lust, das Leuten zu erzählen, dass ich Nine-Gag schon seit ganz, ganz am Anfang kenne, wo das noch so ein ganz kleiner Blog war. Hast du mal das gepostet? Nee, das ist ja mittlerweile nur noch Quatsch. Also das ist ja nur noch so alles umgezeichnet, 5000 Mal gesehen und so. Aber um wegen Film verlassen, wegen MacBank, das fand ich so wahnsinnig interessant, weil dieser Film wusste ich vorher auch nicht, der ist halt dummerweise, ich habe in Deutsch reingegangen und der ist aber auch in Englisch in diesem Shakespeare-Sprech mir deuchtet wer ein Vogel. How does our programs cost? Und ich bin halt echt, da war ich schon in der Schule mega schlecht, ich kapier das halt nicht. Ganz ehrlich, da bin ich einfach zu dumm dafür. Obwohl du ja ein Muttersprachler bist. Ne, es ist ja mega schön auch, und das Ding ist, ich bin auch drin geblieben, war stark und hab's durchgezogen. Nach einer halben Stunde checkst du das auch und dann gewöhnst du dich an ein Sprechen und dann weißt du auch so grob, worüber die eigentlich reden und so. Und ich hab mir ja auch vorgenommen, ein paar Sachen zu übernehmen, die die sagen, zum Beispiel, ich komme zu spät, jetzt immer zu sagen beim echten Leben so, die Zeit war mir unhold. Sich das anzugewöhnen, immer so, ja die Zeit war mir unhold. Das ist so cool, wenn das wirklich, unser Deutschlehrer hat das immer gesagt, wird so gesprochen und es ist einfach cool, wenn es einfach zu einer Persona geht. Es ist auch mega schön, es ist alles supergut, aber es ging ja auch im Film. Die Leute sind original, also genau wie ich, die auch verpeilt haben, dass es auf dieser echten Sprache ist, sind einfach gegangen. Also original, nach fünf Minuten sind halt irgendwie die Hälfte des Kinos einfach gegangen. Ach, die Hälfte, scheiße. Also fast die Hälfte, so ein ganz kleines Kino, also wir waren irgendwie eh nur so, ich schätz mal jetzt 40 Leute, und das sind so ungefähr 15 Leute, sind einfach gegangen. Das sind fünf Minuten. Und das Problem ist, ich wollte auch gehen, aber ich habe diesen Moment verpasst, mitzugehen oder vorher zu gehen. Und das geht so nützlich, das hast du halt so da. Solche Gedanken mache ich mir halt so, im Dunkeln. Ich könnte einfach auch gehen, ist doch scheissegal. Aber ich denke mir so, jetzt kann ich nicht mehr gehen, weil jetzt denken ja alle anderen, wenn ich jetzt gehe, bin ich so ein Mitläufer, der nur geht, weil die anderen gehen. Geschnitten wegen fragwürdiger Überleitung. Aber wir würden natürlich auch gerne mal bei euch eingeladen werden.
Ja klar.
Subtil auf Einladung hinladen.
Betonung liegt auf subtil in diesem Fall.
Machen wir eine Crossover-Folge, so Simpsons meets Futurama. Wer ihr jetzt seid von beiden, könnt ihr euch aussuchen.
Klar, ich glaube, wir sind dafür alles offen.
So eine Importeaternummer.
Genau, klingt gut.
Das hat eins zu eins Nieders Burgelberg genauso gesagt. Das sind die Antworten, die Gäste, die Geisterbahn, How to behave in anderen Podcasts. Pass auf, Nils hat das bestimmt so gesagt. Nee, wir haben tatsächlich so ... How to behave in anderen Podcasts, so Gunnar Brunich. Ich glaub, Nils hat das bestimmt genauso gesagt, weil ich ja immer denke, ich kann ja für die anderen nicht sprechen. Wenn ich jetzt irgendwie sage, ja geil, boah, lass morgen direkt machen. Okay, zwei von drei haben es ja schon gesagt. Wir brauchen eigentlich noch Herm, aber wir fänden es auch lustig, wenn wir Herm als einzigen nicht einladen würden. Den konnten sie nicht ausschliessen, auch in der Crossover-Vorgabe. Ja, das sind wir mitzut und auch fragen. Einfach um euch als Kuppe zu zerstören, dass wir irgendwo so diese Saatkorn setzen, des Hasses in Herm, der ist einfach, warum wir nicht einladen. Wenn du einen wählen müsstest zwischen Herm und Nils, der bei einem atomaren Nuklearschlag nicht stirbt, wen willst du von beiden nehmen? Ey, da ist so eine Frage beantwortet ich nicht. Das ist ja Quatsch. Wenn du... Ne, warte mal, um Florian zu nerven, beide. Beide, durch den Kniff, also beide Tote. Es war eine Riesenehre, dass du hier warst. Ja, mir auch, danke. Vielen Dank für die Einladung. Ja, vielen Dank nochmal auch von mir und ich wünsche dir einen guten Heimweg zurück nach Berlin. Danke, Stefan. Und Grüße an die ganze Gästeliste Geisterbahn-Sippe. Mach ich. Im gesamten Podcast-Suppe, vom gesamten Team. Im Namen. Im Namen des ganzen Podcast- ganzen Podcasts. Aber der Kranz wäre nicht nötig gewesen. Nee, oder? Haben wir auch gedacht. Aber wir hatten wir nicht mehr wieder bei den PayPal-Einnahmen.
Ciao. Das war jetzt das Ende. Das war dieses berühmte Podcast. Субтитры создавал DimaTorzok